Wait, where's my game?
Oh, there it is.
Welcome to Half-Life 1, part 3.
I feel like if you say Half-Life and 3...
In the same... In the same sentence, people will become a little wacko.
You bought the entire set?
Thank you!
Can't wait to use your shaker cup at the gym.
Oh, yeah.
I had a... My... I had a drop... GamerSupps merch drop today!
So... Buy it as a birthday treat!
Oh my gosh!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Code Boomer, yeah.
So...
I posted about it on Twitter and on...
What's it called?
The YouTube community.
Sorry, my brain is so...
I have a question.
Does Half-Life 2 end on a... A cutscene?
No, not a cutscene.
Oh my gosh!
Sorry!
I'm really... Okay!
No!
A cliffhanger!
It does?
No way!
So that's why... I can't believe it's a cutscene.
I can't believe it's a cutscene.
No way!
So that's why people...
Want a third one.
Oh no!
Am I gonna be upset?
Play it... I don't have my... I don't have a Half-Life 3.
I also did not realize Butt Pickle is on the cup.
Yeah, it is!
Code Yowie!
Whose code is that?
Mr. B, happy birthday tomorrow by the way!
Happy birthday!
You're up soon!
You got the whole minky set... Thank you!
Thank you!
It's berries... Oh...
As... As...
As funny...
We can make haha jokes, but let's not...
You know...
Let's not... You know...
I have my own code too, so...
I can joke about it because like...
If it's me and Doki, we're...
We're joking ourselves...
Together...
But you know...
Let's...
Yeah... Code Boomer!
Code Boomer!
But lots of people have code, so...
You know...
I guess you can use whatever one you want...
But don't tell me if you use somebody else's code!
Only tell me if you used my code!
Okay?
Okay!
Half-Life 2...
Episode 2 does...
But Episode 1 and 2 are essentially...
Continuations of the main Half-Life 2 campaign...
Wait...
What do you mean...
Episode 1...
Episode 2?
Also Zalkin...
Thank you!
You're gonna...
Will Half-Life 3 into the world?
I know!
I'm really hoping!
Because you know what also happened...
Is I got really...
Really into Metal Gear...
And everyone was always saying...
That...
A Metal Gear Solid 3 remake...
Was gonna happen...
Everybody was...
Like for years...
And years...
People were hinting at it...
And then I...
Played it...
And I...
Got really into it...
And then they announced...
Delta!
So...
I'm just saying...
Yeah...
For like 10 years...
They were saying that there was going to be a Metal Gear remake...
Metal Gear Solid 3 remake...
So...
I don't know!
I might...
Have the gift of...
Prophecy!
It's not like I used your code...
On my full set of Minto Gamer Sub merch or anything...
Thank you!
I'm sorry Minto I only want...
It's okay!
No no no no no no...
I'm not...
Don't worry I'm not mad...
Don't worry...
I'm sorry...
Sorry if it came off as like...
Minky...
I think it's just uh...
JB...
I think it's just like uh...
How do I say?
Something to remind everybody in general...
You know?
Also for like...
Even in not my chat...
And other people's as well...
You know?
Like...
Oh my gosh...
Please!
Minto is forever...
Thank you!
I don't need a second installment of healthcare plan!
What do you mean a weekly thing you literally donated yesterday?
Thank you so much though...
Thank you Kanye East!
Thank you and also Anonymous...
Will I be playing the two DLCs for this game?
Um...
No pressure with the dono...
Just really enjoy the minky song!
Um...
Uh...
Maybe...
I don't know what the DLCs are...
So...
I wouldn't say...
I wouldn't say no...
May...
Maybe...
Uh...
Maybe if like...
Well the DLCs are not canon...
Oh really?
Oh they're much shorter!
Do you think I could do...
If there's two of them...
Could I do both in one stream?
Hmm...
Blue Shift lets you play as Barney!
They're...
Okay...
Maybe they're not that short...
Understandable...
They're...
Uh...
Let's play as Barney...
Wow...
I think Blue Shift you can beat in one stream...
Oh okay...
Okay...
Good to know...
Did you see the tweet by G-Man's voice actor?
No!
Actually I don't get anything...
Uh...
Half-Life in my timeline at all...
Maybe...
I don't know why...
I guess I haven't tweeted enough about it...
But...
I don't see anything...
About it...
Ever...
Will I play Black Mesa?
I'm also...
Not sure about that one yet...
Just because...
Um...
Uh...
It is a...
Remake...
Of this game...
We'll see...
Might be cool to see how...
Wait...
No...
Sorry...
Yeah...
A remake...
Sorry...
I was thinking of...
What was it...
Half-Life Alyx...
I can't tell gamers up shirt to work...
I work at home...
See...
It is safe for work...
It's pretty different...
Oh...
Yeah...
Maybe once I'm done with the series...
True...
Mm-mm...
Yeah...
Worth playing later...
It would be cool to also...
Go through the series...
And then...
Come back to...
What is supposed to be the beginning game...
Right?
The Black Mesa...
So...
It's...
Kind of like...
Not a...
It's almost like a refresher...
But then it's also new at the same time...
Mm-mm...
Yeah...
You know...
Sometimes...
I wanna play a game series...
But the vibes...
Aren't...
Maybe I'm waiting for something...
Uh...
Or the vibes aren't right...
Or whatever...
Whatever...
You know...
Thank you...
That'll do...
Big hypers...
Yeah...
I totally didn't buy your Gamersubs cup...
For the color changing panto...
I swear...
It's kind of genius though...
No...
Right...
When I thought of that...
I was like...
Whoa...
I think my brain is cooking...
I bought it for the box...
The idea of coming back to the start...
Is why I want Metal Gear 1 2 remakes in 3D someday...
I can see that...
I just hope that with Metal Gear 1...
I wish...
I would want them to put them both into one game probably...
Because with Metal Gear 1...
I would be too afraid of them...
Adding erroneous stuff...
And characters that don't matter...
Because Metal Gear 1 was already so...
Like you know...
Bare bones in terms of story...
But...
2...
Metal Gear 2 has a lot of story...
Looking at the Final Fantasy 7 Remake...
What's that?
I...
Loved the first part of the Final Fantasy 7 Remake...
Final Fantasy 7 2 Remake...
I fear the ending of it is...
But there's a...
There's gonna be a third part...
But I fear the ending of the...
Second part...
Does not...
Make me confident...
I don't know...
I really...
I loved the whole game...
Up until the end...
I really...
Loved the whole game...
Up until the end...
But yeah...
I don't wanna spoil anything...
How are you doing out of 10 today?
Thanks Jay!
Thank you for asking...
I am...
6 out of 10...
I have...
I have a little bit of light sensitivity today...
Hmm...
There's always something wrong...
It's hard to explain...
They're not really DLC...
More like...
Separate expansions of the main story...
Bits and pieces are canon...
But not the full thing...
Much shorter...
Especially Blue Shift...
Also Half-Life Decay...
Exists...
Is that the other one...
Called?
Also...
Thank you so much...
Thank you so much Felix...
For the pink!
Thank you!
Hmm...
6 is decent...
Yeah!
I'm feeling...
I'm feeling pretty good today...
All things considered...
Even if I called...
A cliffhanger...
A cutscene...
After 2 hours of waiting...
To be able to buy everything...
I was finally...
Oh!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I hope...
I hope you guys...
Um...
If everybody...
Hi!
I know some people were kind of like...
Hesitant about the design...
And...
I get it!
Because...
Uh...
It is a...
The...
The panties showing is a little more...
And I...
I wouldn't even wear it myself...
Which is so bad!
Um...
But...
Even though I have...
Worn...
Shirts that...
Have like...
Eroge on it...
But it's like...
I don't know...
That was a long time ago...
But I never wore the...
Ahegao t-shirt...
I can say...
100% I'm wearing it to my...
Upcoming work performance evaluation...
Just always...
Just don't turn your back on them...
You know?
But...
What I wanna say is...
Even if you don't buy it...
That's totally okay...
Not every...
I...
I will make more shirts in the future...
And not every...
Merch drop is gonna be for everybody...
And...
Um...
Yeah...
Just don't...
Don't worry about it...
If you're just like...
Ah...
I wanna support her...
But the shirt is not really my thing...
That's okay...
You know?
You're not gonna make me upset...
Mmm...
It's all good...
And I think that applies to...
All merch...
In the future...
You know?
For anybody...
Um...
You know?
Don't force yourself...
Don't...
Especially if it's like...
Something that...
Will hurt your paycheck...
Or anything so much...
Minto eroge shirt...
Got it...
You know?
So...
Don't feel like you're a bad fan...
If you don't buy...
Um...
Uh...
Every single merch...
Or anything like that...
So...
Mmm...
Yeah...
Don't worry about it...
The design is so you though...
Thanks?
I think...
Uh...
Mmm...
So...
Yeah...
As an enjoyer of the bakery...
I love it...
Good to know...
Um...
The main...
Half-Life 1 expansion...
Is called Opposing Force...
And you play as one of the soldiers...
That come...
To clean up Black Mesa...
What?
That's kinda cool actually...
Jukebox...
Welcome to membership...
Thank you...
Got the full set...
Thank you, Sissy...
Have I been following...
HRT...
The...
Horse...
Race...
Yes...
Well...
Okay...
I...
Someone told me about it...
The other day...
And I've been watching them...
But I'm not...
Like...
I'm not...
Um...
I don't have like...
A horse Oshi...
Or anything yet...
So...
I'm...
I'm not super deep in...
I've only just been placing...
I've been placing bets casually...
But I'm not...
Super...
Uh...
For those...
Hold on...
What's it called again?
Horse...
Uh...
Hold on...
What's it called?
What's the last one?
Uh...
Test?
Horse...
Is it?
Yeah...
Horse...
Race...
Test...
So...
It's so funny...
Because it's like...
Kind of...
It's...
It's like...
I bet...
Like...
I bet the...
The...
Like...
English...
Tuma Musume...
Team...
Are like...
Punching the air right now...
Half...
Because they're just like...
It should've been us!
And half...
Because it's...
People are like...
They're getting into...
Horse girls!
Girls...
Haha...
Just...
If you are so confused about what's going on...
I also don't really quite understand it...
But...
Just go to...
It's on Twitter...
The account is Horse Race Tests...
Yeah...
Just look it up...
And there's like so much art of it and everything.
It's just kind of... Where did it come from?
I don't... I don't know anything that's happening.
I don't... I don't... I don't actually... I'm not as chronically online as I think some people think I am.
So... And especially recently, I've been so busy.
I go to Twitter, I was like... What is this?
I will be financially...
irresponsible all on my own.
That is your decision in panic.
I'm not gonna be... I'm not your mom.
Pressing X to Dow.
I'm not!
What?
No, I've been so busy.
Oh my gosh.
Can I say this?
Yeah, probably.
I've talked about how I am working on my first ever 3D concert.
And that... And that...
Uh... I will... When I go to Japan next... That... I will be recording for it.
Uh... But what you guys don't know... What you guys don't know... Is... I will... I will be gone.
I actually had to change my dates a little bit.
Because I... I... I... I needed to add one extra day... Of rest.
Because on that trip... I will not be... Doing... One... 3D... Recording.
I will not be doing...
Two... I will not be doing... Three... I will be doing... Four... Four... Three D things... While I'm there.
So... Yeah... I've been crazy busy.
Four... Four... I... I was like... I'm gonna make the most of this trip.
So... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four... Four Your ghost maid is busy,
busy, busy, busy, busy, so, yeah!
I have much, much, much to do, and I don't have time to scroll on Twitter.
Will the 3D concert consist of your singing while climbing the stairs?
Gator Ladder.
Let me write down something real quick.
Okay.
You're working so hard, man.
Wow, yeah!
Discovered you through your VODs of Half-Life.
Oh, thank you!
Black Mesa Remake makes references to the sequels, which you'll miss if you're not caught up.
Oh, so then it would be good for me to play that last.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the Zoomer chat, I really appreciate it.
Thanks for sticking around.
Speaking of horses, I found a song last week called Half Horse, Half Man.
About a centaur with dating issues.
And it was reminded of me!
Also, thanks, Murphy.
Thanks, Gator.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We appreciate you working so hard, Minto.
Climbing in 3-hee.
Woo-hoo!
It all, it all...
It wasn't meant to be like this.
At first, it was just two things I was recording, and then it turned into three.
And then it turned into four.
And then I was like, I...
Which is great because, um...
Because of the timing of when I'm going, my plane ticket was very expensive.
So I was like...
I was like, whew!
I at least only have to...
I don't have to keep going multiple, multiple times.
Only twice in June.
So, yeah.
It's a lot of...
I've been dancing a lot.
I've been learning a lot of songs.
And then I also have two covers coming out in the next couple of weeks.
So, I have another cover I need to record for.
It's been busy, busy, busy, busy, busy.
Busy, busy, busy, busy, busy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wisps eating good.
Anyway.
Shall we?
Shall we continue?
There's a piece of gym equipment that's a laddered treadmill.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Your streams have been helping me through it.
Have you seen that somebody did your outro, but with...
I did!
With the Half-Life sound effects.
I did see that.
It's so silly.
But I hope you feel better.
Is it Pi-Kest?
Pi-Chest?
Pi-Pi-Pi-Kest?
Because it will make you so much feel better.
I hope.
Soon.
Sending my gamer subs.
Boomer Code Savings.
Be a Superjet.
Thank you, Korean Ninja.
Thank you.
Thank you for spoiling us with lots of minto.
I'm trying to make up for when I first came back and I had literally nothing planned.
I came back last year and I was just like...
Just shrug.
I have no...
I had nothing.
I'm making up for lost time.
My Yoshi stole my idea.
I could die happy now.
Let's see.
Load game.
I remember, everybody.
I remember that with this, I need to go to the right.
I remember that we went through the water and I saved my game looking at the...
The water on the right.
And we need to jump into that.
I remember.
Despite...
Despite everything going on in my brain right now.
I remember.
I didn't even have to watch the VOD for a recap.
Which now that I say it, it sounds suspicious.
But I really didn't.
Okay?
I...
I didn't foregore.
No, no, no.
It's true.
She Septembers.
I remember that I have to jump into the...
This one!
Right here.
Oh, wow.
It's literally right where I left off.
Okay.
We got our guns.
This is a C4.
This is the mine.
This is a gun and a crowbar.
And we came from here.
Right?
Oh!
Yeah, I killed those guys.
Um...
My health is not looking so great.
But, uh...
We'll...
We'll make it work.
I'm looking at audio real quick.
This should be fun.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, oh.
Oh, thank goodness.
We're fine.
It's right here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, sorry.
My health is at 100, but my armor is only at 15, so...
Fish and mail.
Okay, okay.
All right, let's go down.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh no, are those...
Are those, um...
Are these guys going to hurt me?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Oh, jeez.
I don't want to die.
Wait, ow!
I don't want to die!
Uh...
Leeches!
This way.
Down.
Around.
Oh, loading.
Around town.
Keep going.
Oh, no.
O2 gone.
O2.
Dead.
Here.
Where?
Oh, no!
Wait!
Oh, I made it.
What just happened?
Wait, how did my health get to 100?
How did that happen just now?
It comes back?
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Um...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Can I get through here?
Doesn't seem like it.
Uh...
Andragos, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you!
Sorry.
Also, if my mouse jerks around a little bit, it's plugged up right now because it was, uh...
Oh, I have to crouch through there.
Okay, okay.
It's plugged up because it was dying.
Ah!
Okay.
I think we're good.
We're not good.
I think I went the wrong way.
Oh, I'm lost.
I'm gonna die!
No!
In here.
No.
Everything's okay!
Everything's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Not even close.
Yeah, not even close.
I'm gonna get my gun ready.
What was that?
Was that a naked man?
Thank you for all your hard work, Vito.
Thank you!
Okay, there's something in the water.
I saw him.
Fish!
Is it time to fish?
Oh, there he goes.
Oh, he's so fast.
He can't get me.
How do I get that?
What the heck is that?
How do I get that thing?
Dave the diver time.
No way.
Oh, it looks like maybe I go up.
Wait, how do I go up?
Over here?
Let's try it.
Did you see it?
See what?
They said it was hauled from the Challenger Deep.
But I'm positive that beast never swam in terrestrial waters until a week ago.
There's a tranquilizer gun in the shark cage.
But I'm not sure it would work on this species.
You are welcome to try.
I think it'll work.
Probably.
Oh, no.
All right.
Let's go.
Don't mind me.
I'm balancing.
What if I use my gun on it, too?
I mean, guns are pretty effective, you know?
Wait, so it's a tranquilizer, but it looks like a crossbow.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Come here, little fish.
How do I get out of here?
What the hell is this?
Oh, gosh.
I'm stuck in the water?
Okay.
What the hell is this?
Can I move in this thing?
No.
Oh, God.
This is kind of silly.
Wait.
Am I even hitting it?
I think this is kind of silly.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
You got it at least once.
Do I...
Can I use my other guns to kill this thing?
Just use the pistol?
Underwater?
No.
Oh, it doesn't work underwater.
I see.
Wait.
Actually...
Oh, there it is.
Let me try it then.
Where are you?
I'm afraid.
What if it breaks though?
Hello?
Um...
Can I...
Can I do this on it?
Wait.
Actually, let's do...
Is it this one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is he?
Let's use the...
I don't want to move because it's going to drive me through the water.
There.
Um...
Okay.
Oh!
Maybe that worked!
Maybe that helped.
Maybe...
Oh!
Oops.
No.
Wait.
There we go.
Okay.
It didn't...
How do we know?
How...
You didn't...
Oh.
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
Where...
We'll...
We'll get his ass.
Okay.
I give up.
All right.
I'm gonna save.
Oh!
Wait.
I'm stuck.
That was sweet salvation for a moment.
Wait.
I thought...
Oh!
Please!
Please leave me alone!
Somehow...
Somehow I made it!
Somehow we...
We did it!
Oh golly!
Yeah!
Yeah.
I didn't panic even once.
What was you...
What are you talking about?
Uh...
Oh.
What are you talking about, huh?
Wait.
Why did it...
There we go.
I guess I gotta go down.
Okay.
Oh!
Here we go.
Maybe.
What is this?
Mr. Scientist?
He'll be fine, right?
Oh, it's crossbow ammo.
Ah, I see.
Oh, wait.
Let's save.
Oh, this is evil.
This is so nasty.
Don't like that.
Reload.
Someone juxtaposed this clip with MGS1 Snake beating the Heinen.
Oh man.
No.
Fragging about it to Otacon.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep getting all these guys.
I don't like them.
Barnacles.
Let's get my ammo.
Oh wait.
I already saved.
Oh my gosh.
I should have known better.
Okay.
Now they're all taken care of.
If I go down there, will I be ambushed?
Everyone falls for it.
Slippery.
Maybe.
Ouch!
I need the medical attention.
Half-life.
Less than half-life.
Maybe it wasn't worth it.
Quarter life.
Wait.
Oh, oh.
Slippery.
Where am I?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, okay.
Careful.
Oh.
Wait, is there another machine?
Or monster in here?
Wait, what is this?
Oh my god.
There's two of them.
Okay.
All right.
Maybe this is best then.
Maybe revolver is best then.
I don't have so many bullets, but as long as I don't fall into the water, right?
I'll be okay.
Maybe.
Okay.
I know there's gonna be somebody else that shows up.
I'll be over
there.
I'm so cute.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, we're fine.
Yeah, save now, so true.
Wait, I will save once we get to the other side.
Right here, here, here, baby.
He's gone.
We don't have to worry about him.
Okay, and...
Nice.
Nice, and then this seems pretty, I have to like, what, crouch jump?
Or do I jump from this side?
No.
Or I could, wait.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
I feel like I have to, let me try from here.
Oh, uh...
Don't look at me.
Can you shoot the cable?
We could try.
No.
No, unfortunately.
He's looking right at me, I don't know.
No.
Creep.
Oh, oh.
I'm so close.
Wait, don't come.
Don't come here.
Don't come over here.
Please.
I'm so close.
Just use your arm.
Gordon Freeman!
Is it a crouch jump on that part?
Or is it a crouch jump here?
Or...
Okay.
All right.
Crouch jump everywhere.
Got to use the slip and slide.
Oh, to get into this?
Oh, like a...
Oh...
Like a diagonal?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Then I should be...
Oh.
Okay, yeah, I got a crouch.
Leave me there.
Don't you growl at me.
Oh my gosh, the runway.
Now debuting Minky's latest design.
Oh.
Let's go.
Let's heckin' go.
No leeches.
Oh my gosh.
Who is that?
I got him.
That was G-Man, wasn't it?
Why is he so obsessed with me?
I think I saw something else over there.
I want to try this thing.
Oh, this guy is pretty good, huh?
He broke the rope.
He does want me so bad.
Obsessive behavior.
Hold on.
We can make that!
What?
What just... what just appeared?
Okay.
I'm leaving.
Generator control.
I don't want to save just because I accidentally took that one hit.
And so, just in case.
You know what I mean?
If I can get more health, then I will save.
But for now...
For now, I don't want to do it just yet.
Beep.
What did I do?
Whoa!
Oh, it's a headcrab!
It's my sister and Mai's birthday!
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course!
Here, let me get out of this noisy room.
Make a manual save true!
Mai!
I heard it's your birthday!
Happy, happy birthday to you!
Thank you so much, Bilal!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to your sister!
Okay.
The fire on the crossbow is a sniper scope.
Really?
Wait.
No way!
What's going on down here?
Oh!
It's dark!
I don't like that!
Wait.
It's so dark in there.
More ammo.
I'll take it.
Flashlight!
Oh yeah!
I do have a flashlight!
You're so right!
I'm scared!
Man, you will save.
In case I get ambushed.
Whoa!
You know what?
This is good enough.
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
Time to platform, baby!
Do I need that?
Does this push too?
Do I need these?
I sure hope not.
Not time to get squished!
Oh.
Wait!
What happened?
Huh?
How did I...
How did that happen to me?
I jumped into the squisher.
How could this happen to me?
So close.
So stinking close.
Greedy?
Yeah, little.
Hi, Karim!
Whoa!
Thank you so much!
I'm with the science team.
Thank you so much for the Huckazoo one!
Thank you!
Okay, let's switch back to a revolver.
Or crossbow is pretty good too.
Wait a second.
I want to redo that.
You jerk!
He shoots so fast!
10 HP do-o-o-roar!
Yeah!
I mean it's everything!
Everything!
Okay.
I dodged it.
And then...
Plant a mine!
Oh!
That's so smart!
What?
Okay, hold on.
Maybe like this one?
Wait, where does he spawn?
Like here?
I don't think it worked.
He's too small!
I didn't want to do this before because I didn't know.
Well, I guess I...
I don't know.
I placed it too high!
We're not heading back there, right?
Are we?
We don't need to go back, right?
No?
Okay, then.
We're fine.
Let's keep going.
The trip mines are not effective.
The creature is mint-o-sized.
Hey, hey, hey.
What if...
But actually, what if one of those guys does show up, you know?
I see him right there.
I think I can get him.
Oh my god, look at his eyeball.
What if...
What if the army shows up and I do get them?
With the bob?
You know.
With the bob.
Who knows?
We don't know.
Kinda like the crossbow.
Kinda like...
Did I just see someone walk in?
Wait, did I just see something walk in?
I don't know.
Oh, there's a man!
Welcome to the Crossbow Club.
Hey, cute.
Alright.
Oh, how are you alive?
Yes.
The science team has been tracking your progress with the Black Mesa security system.
Unfortunately, so is the military.
That suit of yours is full of tracking devices.
Still, it's better than going naked in this place.
Naked?
It's cold in there, and you'll have to hurry.
It could sap your suit power in a matter of moments.
If you're bent on reaching the Lambda complex, then you'll want to keep to the older industrial areas where the security system is full of holes.
Okay.
Someone's in the walls.
Who am I hearing?
Wait, so where do I need to go?
Through here?
Someone's in the walls, mister.
Wait, what did I just do?
Sorry.
I think I destroyed...
I activated the button.
Oh, it's an eye scan.
Oh, okay.
Wait, so...
Beep, beep, beep, boop, boop, boop.
How?
Where do I...
Behind him?
Oh, oh!
I got it!
Yeah, I think you should stay here.
I don't think you should come with.
I don't think you should come with me.
I'm scared.
Save, I already did.
I did save, I did.
Oh my goodness.
Why is it so shaky?
Wait, why is it like this?
Oh, because I'm cold?
Oh my gosh.
Is this like a...
Run through it kind of area?
Uh...
Go, go, go, go.
Am I still cold?
What?
Okay, I'm not cold anymore.
Yippee!
Okay, uh...
I only lost a little bit of armor.
But...
Okay, uh...
Go down.
There we go.
Anything around here?
Why is it so...
Feels so ominous?
Any items?
No, okay.
Hush chat?
Wait, what do you guys say?
If you guys see spoilers, I have a spoiler policy.
Where, um...
Where if you see spoilers, you can do a smiley face.
And it shows me that there are spoilers in the chat so I don't look.
And also, it helps push the comment off the screen.
So that I...
Um...
Don't see it.
On accident.
But typically, in these types of games, I'm always like...
My brain is, you know...
Focused.
So I'm sorry if I don't see chat very easily.
Uh-oh, why is it giving me health?
Oh, oh boy.
I'm scared.
Oh!
I just like smiley faces.
I can't spoil what I've never seen before.
Yeah, I can see...
There you go.
Okay.
Uh...
I'm just...
There's more health?
Ah!
Shit!
Screw you!
I like the way they run at me.
Ugh!
I guess I could grab the health.
Oh, wait.
I'm back to Crowbar.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Oh my gosh!
There's so much health!
Do we come back here?
Or...
Yes.
You can?
No.
Just go?
Okay.
Okay, I'll trust you guys.
Oh, yeah.
It's an elevator.
Oh, Barney!
Make sure you don't...
Who?
He was supposed to be...
Safe!
Barney!
I should've...
I should've stayed in front of him!
I didn't shoot him!
It wasn't me!
Are we gonna be fighting against a sniper?
Oh my god.
Ah!
Holy hell.
Oh my god.
Ah!
What the hell?
Oh!
Sexy lady!
Wait, there's more of them.
I think?
Are you a sexy lady?
That's a generator?
Hi, Dak!
Uh...
Just got hope from work and got back on the stream.
Barney instantly dies!
No!
Oh my
god.
This is on normal easy...
Yeah, it's on normal mode.
How many are there?
She was so fast.
Okay!
Um...
Ma'am?
Use the shotgun.
Is it better?
Oh!
Oops.
Sorry.
More likely to hit.
Well, I guess that's true.
Lady.
Lady, where'd you go?
Lady!
I hear another?
Just like your friend.
Where are you?
She's on...
She's coming.
She's on her way.
She's almost here.
She's so close.
I don't know why she walked up.
But...
Okay.
Are there any more?
Ladies!
Let's all calm down now!
Surface access.
Okay, yeah.
She's still warm.
What do you mean, go for it?
What do you mean by that?
Ladies can't resist.
I forgot my glasses.
I was like, I'm missing something today.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
I completely forgot.
My glasses.
I can't see without my glasses.
There we go.
I can't believe I forgot.
Now that's why my aim was so bad and it will be perfect.
No.
Yes.
Jinkies.
Oh wait, let me just get my shotgun.
Oh.
This is huge.
Alright.
I'm just going to keep destroying every box I see now.
I love the structure.
Thank you.
Monalifter.
Oh my gosh.
The buff Mona Lisa is insane.
I'm searching the area.
Dr. Freeman, now I recognize you.
Another!
Wow.
They're really...
They're like, hey, if that fight was too hard for you...
Are we gonna...
Is there more to happen in here?
I'm so nervous.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what?
Alarming amount of health.
Yeah, I'm so...
I'm scared.
I'm scared as hell right now.
Hahaha.
Okay.
I'm sorry, Barney.
I'm sorry.
It should've been me.
I should've been the one to take the hit.
Wait, hold on.
Oh yeah.
Let's go up here first.
Okay.
Does this...
Oh, that probably opened...
Oh gosh.
It probably opens that up.
Hold on.
Okay.
Before we do that...
Ah!
Oh.
Ouch.
I'm stupid.
Um...
Nevermind.
Okay.
Uh...
We're gonna go in there.
Okay.
Both
those ninjas go invisible!
That's insane.
Okay.
Mint failed the quick time event to save Barney.
Joking.
Hahaha.
Thank you for including the joking part.
Wait.
Okay.
Here we go.
Thank you, Glint.
Thank you so much.
I miss Barney already, too.
Oh, more health?
Why?
Ah!
Get him out.
Oh!
I'm shooting!
Nice hit.
See what?
Alright, we got him.
What?
They got me!
Nap time.
Body.
Wet body.
Hahaha.
No.
No, I have nothing.
Not even...
I don't have a crowbar.
I have nothing.
Oh!
Woohoo!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, it's a double...
Okay.
Double set.
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
Ugh.
Ah!
Oh, I'm gonna die.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't realize I needed to crouch.
Okay.
You psychos!
Uh...
A door, perhaps?
Oh!
There's that.
Uh...
Body?
What body?
I...
Oh my gosh.
I could've totally lived through there.
Hahaha!
Oh, come on!
I could've totally...
Wait, what's that on the other side?
Made that...
Oh!
My crowbar!
And then I think we go back to the other, other side.
Oh!
I'm taking damage, but I have to do that.
Wait.
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
Go back up.
There we go.
Or maybe it's this one down here.
Oh, the bridge.
Oh, you're right!
There totally is a bridge!
You're right.
Ah, there we go.
Ew!
Okay.
I'm outside.
You're nasty.
Where's all my stuff?
I just got the crossbow!
It was so awesome!
Stinky...
Sewage...
Come here.
Will he drown down...
Oh my god!
The little bubbles!
Can they breathe underwater?
Or...
They'll die eventually, no?
It's drowning.
This is where the baby head crab learns to swim.
You just gotta throw a baby into the water and it will learn to swim out of necessity.
Everybody knows that.
Okay.
Is that a person?
Uh-oh.
Scientist.
Hold on.
I'm gonna check on my mouse real quick because...
See what it's at.
If it's like close to a hundred, then I'll...
Oh yeah!
It's at 90%.
Okay, good.
I can unplug it.
Oh, freedom!
Sweet freedom.
Are you okay?
Oh!
Sorry.
Whoa.
Okay.
Uh...
Do not close outlet without closing intake.
Not anymore.
I don't think he was okay though.
Gonna be honest.
Oh, wait.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Where did I open?
Oh!
I didn't notice this ladder.
If I...
If I jump in there, I'll definitely die.
No.
What a thrill.
Where are we, anyway?
Take a leap.
Okay.
Oh.
We're probably fine.
Barney!
Hey, hey!
Where are you going?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy!
You think he's okay?
Where'd he go?
Um...
Uh...
Do I still only have...
What's in here?
Uh...
Whoa!
Would I lead to this if I had not opened the thing?
Soup.
That's green pea soup, probably.
Why did he run from me?
The ceiling particle god?
Why did he run from me, though?
There's more of them.
These were always here, and I just didn't notice.
No, Bardi.
Buddy.
That was Bardi's leg.
I'm going to do a new save.
Was I supposed to take so much damage dropping from there?
Because, uh...
Oh, there's nothing here.
No, you weren't!
What?
Why did I take so much damage, then?
Oh, the va...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Should I redo it, then?
Hmm.
Would it be worth redoing?
No?
Oh, well, we'll just...
We'll just keep going for now.
High radiation area.
I'm running out of bullets.
Whoop!
More bullets!
Please!
Any in here?
None?
Okay.
Let me go back upstairs.
Real quick.
Check out what's going on in here.
Any bullets?
What the hell is going on in here?
Where are we?
Okie dokie.
I guess I just gotta go inside.
Not enough bullets.
Never mind.
Parkour time?
I guess so?
Where do I parkour from, though?
There's more health down there.
I think we go...
Uh...
Where do I parkour from?
The soup!
There's bowls of soup everywhere!
Oh!
Observation area?
Oh, observation area?
Oh, wait.
That's where I was at.
Hahaha.
Oh, I think I go from here into there!
Oh, that's pretty...
Woo!
Up!
I thought so earlier, but I was like, no!
Surely not!
Okay.
Can I get in, please?
Haha.
I'm crouched.
Oh!
Alright.
Let's...
We don't...
We'll save our bullets.
For right now.
Good platforming.
Thank you.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's observe.
Before we...
Um...
So, almost everything else is the same.
Except this middle one and that back one.
Oh...
It's simpler than it looks, is it really?
Wait.
Now they're getting all out of sync.
Wait a second.
Hahaha.
Mari!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's wait for...
This guy to come up.
And then we'll...
Uh...
Oh...
Oh my god!
Hahaha!
I did it!
Tuh-heh.
Nice.
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh.
Okay.
All right.
So far so good.
Sus pipe.
Yeah.
Okay.
I see the health down there.
Oh.
Wait.
We can get to it.
Oh.
Phew.
Maintenance access.
Oh, does this...
Is this from the other side?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Does this...
Will this unlock?
Aha!
Whoa, Zachary!
Thank you so much!
Got your plush in recently!
Thank you!
Thank you so, so much!
I really appreciate it!
All right, all right, all right, all right.
All right, all right!
Okay!
Uuuh!
Guys, I don't know how I did that, but...
Uh...
Yippee!
Woohoo!
I don't know how I did that.
Who just...
Who...
Who what?
What was that?
It was a Barney.
It couldn't have been.
Okay, I...
I gotta go to the little ghosties room real quick, you guys.
Is that okay?
I'll be right back.
I just gotta...
I gotta...
I'll be right back.
And I'm gonna get some more tea as well.
Drunk dinner...
You can just listen to this...
Factory...
Ambiance...
ASMR...
It sounds so...
Industrial...
Yeah!
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'm back!
There's so much more blood on the ground than before!
Am I supposed to go up there?
Wee!
What if I...
Want the boxes, though?
Oh.
More chunks coming out.
Wait.
What if...
Is there stuff in here?
Oh!
See, see, see!
This is why we check.
Welcome back!
Thank you!
More ammo...
Oh!
And some first aid?
Okay.
I'll take it.
Go get the boxes then.
I will!
Oh.
I'm too speedy.
There we go.
Alright.
Let's go for our little ride.
Ne-hee-hee.
Oh.
Uh.
Okay.
Let's go down here.
Oh.
Caution.
Yes.
There is a caution.
What do I hear?
Okay, I don't hear anything.
Never mind.
Swimming time.
Oh, fire even?
Okay.
I'm gonna get my gun out just in case.
Many...
Many things that will kill us.
Like fire.
And...
There's so many chunks being rained on us even.
Oh.
Crawl, crawl, crawl.
Up, up, up.
Wait, what's happening?
Why can't I go up?
Wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's happening?
Why can't I go up?
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
That was close.
There's a roof there.
Alright.
But we are...
We're...
We were not deterred.
I just hear all the crushing.
Nothing over here?
Okay.
Let's go.
Did I come in here before?
Uh, no.
No, I did not.
Wait.
Yes.
Yes, I did.
Yeah, this is where I fell in.
What if I go through here?
Ah!
I see.
Okay.
Uh, let's see.
Door crossed on the other side.
Yeah, I was locked.
So let's go back in here and get blown by the fan.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
What is going on in there?
Oh.
That's what's going on in there.
Ouch!
Forgot how many hits these guys take.
Party!
We've only seen two parties.
This is the stream!
And both of them!
Both single times!
Dude!
Oh my god, I got my revolver back.
Three?
No, I think only two, no?
At least three dead...
It's not my fault, though.
Push, push.
Hold on.
I want to open that up first.
Alright, now we push, push.
Push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push.
Okay.
Uh, right here.
What'd that do?
It stopped everything?
Oh.
It stopped the squishers?
Um.
Do we have...
Different eyes?
Or...
Oh, I see!
I see!
It stops them for a tad.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Yes, we do.
Okay, okay.
I messed up.
My special eyes.
Look.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Die!
Why didn't I notice this before?
Coming up.
Is this...
Controlling...
Wait, I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Uh, you guys.
I can't move.
Uh.
I'm stuck.
Hold on.
Listen.
This is me jumping.
Grouch.
We did it!
Hahaha.
I'm guessing this changes the direction of the conveyor belt?
So now they're all going down.
Now they're all going in.
I'm just gonna save again.
Oh my gosh, I only have one bullet left because I wasted it on that ugly...
Uh-oh.
A gun with one bullet.
Uh...
Maybe I shouldn't just press it willy-nilly.
Hahaha.
Oh, go, go.
Oh, not...oh.
Ouch.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hahaha.
This one only has five bullets.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
What the?
Oh.
Go, go, go, go.
Weeeee!
What's over here?
Ouch.
Oh, really?
Nothing?
Wow, okay.
Just kidding.
Took damage for nothing.
Hahaha.
Hazardous machinery.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Oh, ow!
Wait, I think that actually saved us some health.
So nice.
Okay.
Yeah, who's going through this?
We're going through it.
Clearly.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, we made it?
Hahaha.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, more.
Alright.
Just once.
One, two, three.
Infectious waste.
What's that mean?
What?
Wait, what does that mean?
What's over here?
Wait, oh, the infectious waste.
Okay.
Hahaha.
Maybe.
Okay, uh...
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
There we go.
Very good.
It's locked!
Um...
What's...
That does nothing.
Okay.
Am I trapped here?
No.
Okay.
Uh...
Hehehe.
Totally OSHA compliant workspace.
Yes.
Oh, golly.
I can't see anything.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Never mind.
Let's just keep going along along.
Keep it strong.
Move along.
Hold on.
What is all this noise I'm hearing?
Okay, not fine.
Um...
Stairs.
Wait.
Is this like a microwave hallway?
Or...
Hahaha.
Um...
Am I gonna get cooked?
Yes.
Chat!
I'm cooked!
Hahaha.
Don't get incinerated.
No...
Uh, wait.
Um...
Wait, which goes to the correct one?
Oh!
Not that!
I just wasted my last bullet!
Okay.
Well...
Um...
What did I just...
Oh.
I think I got her...
Ah!
Oh!
Sorry.
I was trying to save.
Manually.
Let's go in there then!
Cause it seems...
Correct.
Otherwise, they wouldn't have wanted me to shoot that, you know?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
I think it's a necessary.
Oh my god.
Mint is like revenge.
Best served cooked.
Ah!
Game is on hard mode now!
Anything that I can...
Procure?
Oh.
No...
Nothing!
Who changed my settings?
I hear fire...
Wait, am I gonna have to get cooked again?
Are these the stairs?
Are there head...
Are there crabs in here too?
Probably.
Oh my gosh.
How am I supposed to kill you?
With your fists.
Sometimes my...
My cursor...
Or...
Not my cursor.
My mouse doesn't hold down when I'm trying to like...
You know?
So that's...
If you're wondering why I'm like...
Tap-tapping...
It's because of that.
Oh!
We're here!
I have to do it all over again!
Are you kidding me?
Oh!
New mouse fund.
I just bought this mouse recently.
Go back?
Wait, go back where?
I have a ladder.
I did it?
This way?
Was there a ladder here?
Oh, I see it.
Thank you, guys.
I see, I see.
This is giving me like... Astro Bot.
Flashbacks.
I'm guessing it doesn't matter which one I go to.
Or maybe it did.
Uh-oh.
Holy...
Oh, the other one would have been better, maybe.
Oops.
It's quite rude that they put me back here.
Wait, uh... Crouch and go down.
Okay.
Slowly but surely.
Let's try this.
Maybe.
I also could like, go here.
I guess I could have done that.
But I'm not from that height.
I don't think I would have made it.
Yay!
I made it!
Oh...
Those are some long, long tanks.
Okay.
It's really nice that they figure that you might be out of bullets at this point, so they don't like, put them in the middle, you know?
The music.
It's like, I don't think it's music, meant to be music, but it kind of sounds like music.
Okay.
Questionable ethics.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm gonna die here.
Oh!
What?
Game is mean!
Don't you have C4?
Uh...
Yes!
But...
I don't have any grenades!
I have a crowbar and I have C4!
That's it!
Uh, how do I use the C4 again?
Um...
You can throw it.
I can.
Left click throw.
Hold on.
I keep hearing...
One of the sound effects sounds like the AOL, like, door opening sound.
Oh, wow!
They're all dead!
Wow-wee!
Thank you, guys.
I hear something else.
I do hear something.
Lookit there were dogs in their kennels.
Hmm...
Okay, good.
Nice!
Who's in there?
I only have one left.
Oh...
What's going on?
Oh!
Don't come out.
Don't...
I...
I'm safe.
Probably.
Hello.
Oh!
Ouch!
What the hell?
No, no, no.
I'm sorry.
What?
He's in glass!
Wait...
Aw, dang it.
Should I have done that?
You had no choice?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
What is this gonna do?
Kill them all!
Kill them!
Kill the little headcrabs!
Oh!
Nice!
Friendly fire?
Uh...
Is he coming for me?
Ow!
Please!
Oh...
The button.
Maybe I should redo it.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, I know I'm far...
I'm far from where we were, but...
Now I'm prepared.
Oh, I see!
You're right!
I...
I had to do it, so that I could open the door.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Listen now.
Now we have...
Less damage.
Okay, okay, okay.
We'll do this again.
And then we'll lure him into the middle.
And then we'll get him again!
Bait him first, okay.
Nice.
Okay, now open the door.
But the other guy is gonna be there too.
Send the bees!
Will this get him?
Oh, oh, oh!
He's freaking out!
Uh...
Yeah!
I got a new gun.
Uh...
Don't really need that.
Hey, it's no good up there.
It's all sealed off.
The only way out would be to find someone with scanner access who can open the front door.
I'm pretty sure there's a few scientists hiding somewhere in the labs.
Maybe with both of us looking, we can track them down and get them to let us out.
Okay, Barney!
Barney!
I did almost shoot Barney.
I 100% almost shot Barney.
Okay.
Split up, team!
Actually...
Yeah, we might stand a better chance if we team up.
Yeah, yeah.
Come here.
Come on.
Come with me.
Stay behind me, Barney.
Stay behind me.
Um...
Barney might be dead.
Got him?
Don't worry, Barney.
Stay with me.
Stay with me, Barney.
Grabbing his guns.
Oh, there's armor down there.
Hold on, Barney.
Barney.
Okay.
Am I on the desk?
Did I miss it?
I must've.
Oh!
I see it?
Wait, let me...
I don't know why I say it before not...
grabbing that.
Okay.
Thank you!
Save.
Alright, Barney.
Barney.
Barney, move.
What's this say?
Insider!
In...
Uh...
Super...
Bus...
Via...
Oh my god, he just ran in.
Barney, Calhoun!
Wait, no.
What was that?
Uh, Leeroy!
That's what...
That was his Leeroy moment.
Wait, what's over here?
This is a different room.
Uh...
Barney?
Oh, okay.
You're fine.
Come in here.
Come in here, Bar...
No!
Why did you do that?
Why did he do that?
Barney not...
Might...
Might not be as...
Uh...
Wait, what is this?
What the hell is this?
He had no choice.
Yes, he did!
What is he fighting?
What's...
Who is he fighting out there?
Oh, hold on.
I wanna see what this does.
Ah!
It would've obliterated him.
Snarks?
That was the same thing.
Wait, I hear more.
Is Barney dead?
Oh, he's not.
Okay, why not?
Didn't wanna die alone anyway.
Ha!
Idle with the snarks out for some fun interactions.
Oh!
It's kinda cute!
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep!
Ha, ha, ha!
He
was...
Barney's kinda hardcore.
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
No!
Did you kill...
What'd you kill in here?
Oh!
Did you kill them?
With just that?
Barney?
This Barney's the best Barney we could've had!
1v2!
Damn, Barney!
Uh, is this a circle?
Where are we?
Yes.
I just forgot to pick up that gun, apparently.
Barney is the go- Oh!
Oh, wait!
I didn't forget!
Oh, I switched it out!
Or, wait...
That's...
No.
Huh?
That's weird.
Oh, what'd that happen?
Don't worry about it.
Yeah.
Um...
Wait, hold on.
Uh...
I'm trying to figure out...
Before we continue...
Further this way...
We went through here...
Which was from where?
Sorry, I'm just trying to make sure I...
Remember what places we've gone to.
Okay.
So we went up...
And then that lead...
That's just a big circle.
And so we haven't been down...
Here.
Ah, but I cannot.
Okay, okay, okay.
This game is...
Pretty linear.
And then this is the door he says that we need the scientists for.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Under...
Where?
Yeah, we need a science man.
For the scanner.
Which we might find one in here?
Barney?
Be careful.
Uh-oh, what did I do?
Oh.
Oh, there's two of them.
Get Freeman!
Uh, you have more...
Important things to worry about, no?
Use the snarks?
I don't even know how to use them!
What?
I think the door blew Barney up.
No, it didn't.
Barney?
The door crushed him!
Stay...
There.
Stay there.
Yeah, I'll wait here.
Yeah, yeah.
It's exactly what I said.
Does this do anything?
No?
Okay.
Go up first, maybe?
Yeah...
I like how the way they're having us collect all of our ammo and stuff back.
It's pretty fun.
Okay, alright.
Barney?
He's still there.
Okay.
Wee-woo, wee-woo!
Ah, the bees!
Ow, the bees!
Oh god, there's bees!
Ah, the bees!
I'm screwed.
Uh, guys, I'm screwed.
Oh god!
Oh, the bees!
Ah, the bees!
Guys, I'm so screwed.
Wait, did they kill Barney?
I think our first plan was better.
I think if I...
Okay.
I have to...
I have to wait for the...
What's it called, guys?
Throw more snarks?
But I only have five of them.
I don't even know what it did.
What did it do?
I...
You guys can't say use the snarks when I don't know what they do!
What it means!
Toss them and see I did, but I couldn't see what happened!
Okay.
Anyway.
Uh...
Uh, that was a bit chaos.
So, I will...
Um...
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Let the guys come in.
Set up mines too.
Oh, I guess I can grab them real quick.
Yeah.
And, uh...
Set up my own.
But I don't want them to blow up...
Before I...
Okay, hold on.
Um...
I guess I can set one up here.
Probably.
Bring Barney upstairs?
True.
Barney, come here.
Roger that.
Let's run like hell.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
Come here, come here, come here.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Come here, Barney.
Barney?
But don't get attacked by bees.
Come here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Shove them in a safe corner.
Okay.
We'll put one here, I think.
He won't get bee'd if it's here.
Too far.
What do you mean?
We'll see.
Okay, be careful, Barney.
Is it too high?
He's running into action.
Barney's insane.
Barney did it!
Good job, Barney.
Barney.
See, this one did work.
It blew up.
So it did...
It did...
Blow...
Uh...
Maybe...
Oh, I think he touched it.
And he wasn't...
Oh, I get it.
Oh, I'm stupid.
It was so far away, it didn't do anything.
Barney the goal.
Yeah, he is.
Oops.
Wait, I blew it up the star?
I did?
It blew up with the others.
Oh.
Wait, why?
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Why did it blow up when I shot the others?
Chain reaction?
Aw.
Oh, well.
I think we're good.
Hi, Barney.
Okay, we might live longer if we work together.
Yep.
Probably.
Especially you.
Don't touch those.
Oh.
Holy cow.
I just took the...
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go.
Alright.
I'm prepared for this guy now.
I'm prepared for him.
Don't worry, Barney.
Oh.
Did you see that?
Huh.
I only have one left though.
I'll try using a snark.
Next time.
We'll try using a snark.
Okay, here we go.
He's so unimpressed.
He should be really impressed.
You know...
He should be like...
Gosh.
Scared me.
Shotgun.
I guess we could use that instead.
Thanks, Barney.
Ouch!
You're hitting me!
Friendly fire!
Oh, come on.
Ouch!
One hit wonder!
Are you kidding me?
Barney.
Barney!
Oh my god!
Maybe it's for the best.
Sorry, Barney.
I can't save you from a headcrab, buddy.
I just...
I can't go in there.
Not that I really want to.
What...
For the purpose of this room anyway.
Rip Barney.
He was a real one, you guys.
I feel like I'm gonna get ambushed in here.
Oh.
What exploded?
X.
Almost dead.
Did I?
Oh, it was my...
It was a trip...
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay!
Alright.
Barney was invented...
Final destination rules!
No!
Oh!
Okay, we're back here now.
Okay, very nice.
I'm sorry, buddy.
What was that?
Are you shooting at me?
Or...
Oh my god.
Yes, you are.
Ah!
Oh my god, please!
Oh!
I should've just let them...
Aim, Doko!
Please, not today!
I thought I heard someone else.
Um...
Still doing okay.
I suppose.
What's this button do?
What is this thing?
Some kind of weapon?
Put that down.
It's a prototype.
Wait!
They're doing a cutscene that I can't even see!
Hold on!
Oh my god.
He takes so...
They take...
They eat so much damage.
What?
Where's the cutscene?
This?
No!
Where is the cutscene?
You missed the scene!
Hold on.
I'm gonna reload.
Where...
I don't know where it happens.
Oh!
Ah!
I got him.
Oh, just in the hallway?
Oh, wait.
Come back!
Doesn't have cutscenes.
You know what I meant.
Oh.
Thank you.
Okay.
Anyway, those guys are taken care of.
Now...
Now we can listen.
Like, where are the people at?
What do you think?
Is it some kind of weapon?
Put that down.
It's a prototype.
Oh!
Well, isn't it?
It's much too unpredictable.
Don't let it overcharge.
Wait, what do you mean?
Overcharge.
Fancy.
You let it overcharge.
So if I also let it overcharge...
Am I in trouble?
The BFG of the game.
Wait, does it work like the BFG even?
Save and try.
Like that.
The music all of a sudden.
Do not obstruct laser shield.
Okay.
I haven't been.
Oh, okay.
This one's on.
Or as it should be, I suppose.
How many are there?
Hmm.
Holy cow.
Whoa.
One hit.
It's so stinking strong.
Oh.
Okay.
But I probably should not use it.
For, you know, willy-nilly-ness.
Let's use it.
Let's get this.
Yeah.
Only 12 ammo.
Use it in panic.
But that's okay.
We'll maybe get more.
Who knows?
Maybe.
I wish you'd give me more shield, please.
Save it for big boys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll save it for the big boys.
Oh, what's this?
Is that ammo for it?
Oh.
Okay.
Yellow is the ammo.
There we go.
Very nice.
Okay.
We got over here.
Whoa.
Okay.
Cool.
One more to go.
Okay.
Wait.
How much?
Okay.
I still only have one.
That sucks.
Okay.
Save.
Oh.
What?
Uh.
Just kidding.
Um.
The...
Oh, the yellow button.
The one that...
Oh, okay.
This one.
Oh, it didn't do anything.
Oh.
Please watch Half-Life VR, but the AI is self-aware.
You were saying?
Yeah.
Wait.
Is it timed?
Or...
Did it do all that it needed to do?
Okay.
Maybe it's timed.
Uh...
Where at?
What does the sign say?
The do not obstruct laser shield?
The thing...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Uh...
Can I...
Come on.
Um...
Uh...
I didn't collect all the ammo?
I didn't?
Where at?
Oh, wait.
Here?
There we go.
Thank you.
Was there any in here as well?
Let me double check.
No...
Laser.
Is there another box we can...
Use...
Somehow?
Obstruct the shield.
I will!
Give me a second.
Give me...
One second.
One...
Luzon.
Welcome back.
Thank you for two of us.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, wrong one.
Okay.
I had it?
I did?
The shield itself.
Oh, like so...
Oh!
Oh, we need to make it...
So that it doesn't go down.
So the laser...
Will...
Bust through the wall.
I got it.
Look at it.
It's not even that strong.
Took so long to get through this teeny wall.
Is it gonna...
Can we break the ceiling too?
Say that again after you touch it.
That...
It still took two...
Like a...
Two seconds...
To...
To get me.
Woo!
Parkour down.
Aim for the boxes.
Wait.
Uh...
Hold on.
I'm gonna go for the...
Here?
Okay.
Uh...
What else can I...
Oh, land on this.
There we go.
And then this.
Ouch!
I still took damage!
I did my best.
Minus two.
She's a trained professional.
Yeah, exactly.
Mito doesn't need to hear this.
Scientist.
Thank God.
Get us out of here before those military drones figure out where we're hiding.
We all have regional scanner access.
Escort us to the lobby and we can get out of the lab.
Okay.
Oh, there's three of you.
Uh...
Why do you have this?
Oh...
Classic Peter.
That guy Peter.
Okay, you're safe.
Uh, watch out.
Don't touch that part, okay?
You first.
Go.
Open it.
Oh.
Sorry.
Anyway.
Where's our other guy at?
Weren't there... What do you mean?
There's three of you.
Come on.
Beep, beep.
Did I save?
Okay.
Come on.
We got one guy.
He's the realest one here.
Come on.
Let's keep going.
Need to call him again.
Maybe we'll do one at a time.
I don't know.
Whoa.
He's stomping along.
Oh.
He'll run if I do?
Okay.
Come on, buddy.
We only need the one guy, no?
Open it up.
Use it.
Oh.
Good job.
Well, I'll let you know.
But I'm warning you.
It's hell out there.
It's completely under military control.
You'll have to sneak and fight your way from one end to the other.
And I don't expect you'll meet many of our peers along the way.
But if you do survive and somehow make it across the base, you'll end up at the Lambda Complex.
Oh.
Where the rest of the science team has taken shelter.
I wouldn't venture there myself.
But I will let them know that you are coming.
Oh, thanks.
Bye.
Here we go.
We have to sneak and...
Sneak and fight.
Why did he leave?
I don't... I don't know.
Oh.
It's a bad guy, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Is there another guy?
Oh.
Woo!
Let's see.
Oops.
Oh.
Gordon.
Can you hold it for a longer throw?
I don't...
Right, you can't pick them up.
You can't pick them up, you guys.
We tried before in the past.
Right-click to pick up.
No, it doesn't work.
It's only in online mode, apparently.
Oh.
Shoot.
Try my new gun.
Hey!
Try the new gun.
Let's try the new gun.
Nice.
Oh, the scientists.
What?
They said they were taking shelter.
But they're not taking shelter at all.
So sad.
Okay.
If I just...
Wait, am I...
There we go.
Take you too.
This is so sad.
I'm just going to save.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's...
Everything's a-okay.
Even though I...
Wasted...
Everything's not okay.
Where did that come from?
Explode it for fun.
I can't...
Oh.
Oh, with...
This, obviously.
No.
No, no.
I am not going to take damage from my own C4.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
This thing.
There we go.
Okay.
Now we can continue onwards.
Now we can continue...
Oh, let me reload and then save again.
Okay.
I'm more afraid of the military men than I am of the monsters.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm way more afraid of the military men than I am of the monsters.
Oh.
I need...
I did not see that.
Scones.
Pretty good.
Right in the face.
I know.
That was pretty bad, wasn't it?
Oh.
I'm going to restart.
Hold on.
Let's just...
Let's just redo that part.
Right, quick.
Where are they?
Snark time?
Oh, yeah.
Let me try it.
What do I just...
Do I just...
Throw him?
Is there a guy back there?
Yeah.
Can I...
It was worth.
Oh, wait.
I got five more.
Perfect.
Never mind.
Wow.
The snark was so funny.
I liked him.
That was cute.
That was pretty funny.
I like that guy.
Somebody's gone now.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Take it.
I'll take it.
Oh.
Wow.
There's so many.
Generous.
Snark is a lot of fun.
I...
Fuel storage.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
I don't think it will let me pick up this gun.
Or this one.
Okay.
They blow up eventually.
Oh.
I like kind of defending myself with the grenade.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Let's sneak.
We're sneaking.
We're not sneaking.
Just kidding.
We're...
Uh...
Running.
We're running.
Will this work on it?
I think I missed it.
I think I missed.
Was that enough?
Oh,
uh-oh.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's gonna blow up on me.
Oh.
No.
I messed up.
Dang it.
I used up all my ammo.
Maybe it was worth it, though.
For that kind of boss, you know?
Or not a boss, but you know what I mean.
Worth it?
Okay, hold on.
Is there...
I will...
I will save it.
I will save the game.
But I'm gonna make a new save just in case.
Um...
Oh, it's one of these.
Down the hole.
I don't think I can snipe it.
With that...
I don't think that worked.
Right down the barrel.
Okay, hold on.
All right.
I did save.
So, we could just run for it.
And zigzag.
Zigzag.
Okay.
Never mind.
Oh, okay.
It's a good thing we took out the chopper then, actually.
Never mind.
Oh.
Long-range grenade launcher?
I...
Um...
Don't have that.
Can we go into the water?
Oops.
Might as well restore health.
Wait, where?
Oh, with these.
So true.
You're so right.
I was like, There's so many here, and I completely forgot about them.
Okay.
Good thinking.
Good job, guys.
Good thinking, guys.
There's a friend in the water?
Wait, I want to see a friend.
Let's go check him out.
Oh!
He's dead!
Let's see.
Uh...
I don't think I can make that.
The helicopter got him!
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Oh, that's so funny.
I just turned off something.
Um...
Is that...
Can I get him from here?
I don't think it worked.
Oh...
Oh!
Is there anything down here?
Oh, wait.
There's a...
There's a little lever.
Hold on.
This?
Wait.
What opens?
Oh, oh.
Oh, no, scientist.
Thank you.
I'll take that.
Definitely need that.
Okay.
Cool.
Let's keep going.
Let's hope for no friends in the water.
Can I bust this open?
Okay.
Which way shall we go?
Guys, left or right?
Left or right?
Yeah.
Any, many, many, mo.
Catch a tiger by his toe.
If he hollers, let him go.
My mom said to pick the very best one.
And you are it.
To the left.
Take it back now, y'all.
Technically, the left was better.
Because it was close.
Oh, no.
It was closer.
No!
Oh, no.
I have no more ammo.
What's it fighting?
Oh, it gave me ammo for it.
Wait.
Okay.
I'm in.
It gave me ammo for it.
Okay.
Only 20, but it was better than nothing, I suppose.
I'm sorry?
Where the hell did you come from?
Ah!
Oh, my God.
We came to board.
All right.
What I'm going to do is...
Okay.
Let's...
Let's get an idea of what's going on here, you know?
I'm going to climb.
Okay.
There's stuff over here.
That's exciting.
He doesn't see me, does he?
I'm a cactus.
He doesn't see me, will he?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
Okay!
Um...
Hold on.
Let's redo that.
Oh, I forgot about you.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Okay, save.
And... when he's gone.
When he's gone.
We're gonna run when he's gone.
And then we're gonna run back.
We're gonna keep going.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
We're gonna hide.
Oh.
We're gonna get a better gun.
Caution, high voltage.
Okay.
We're sneaky.
We're not sneaky.
Ha ha ha ha.
It's fine.
I just saved.
Let's just see what's going on around here.
Oh, there's a little... there's a little hidey hole.
Oh, awesome.
Storm drain hatch.
Okay.
Perfect.
Sneaky.
Storm... storm drain hatch.
Where?
I can... two can play at that game.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Awesome.
Not awesome.
Scout!
Okay.
I'm just gonna save.
Ha ha ha ha.
And we're gonna run around.
Where was that guy anyway?
Where was that guy camping?
I don't know.
Woo!
Scouts.
I don't... how do... how do we get over here?
Oh.
Never mind.
Sorry.
I did not realize this was the...
What is the tower?
Oh.
I'm working on it.
I'm just trying also to see everything around.
Good.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
See, like, there's stuff in...
There's, like, stuff in here.
I grabbed something, at least.
I'm not quite sure... oh.
Oh.
There was more stuff.
Some more ammo.
Nice.
Okay.
Which...
I'm still on this because I'm using the grenades, but...
All right.
Ikimashou.
Oh, uh, in here.
Storm, drain, hatch.
What did that open up?
Uh...
I did see this here.
Nice.
Ah!
Okay.
All righty.
Storm, drain.
Did we see anything like that?
Yeah, yeah.
Not yet.
Okay.
So maybe it was...
But it says...
Storm, drain, hatch that way.
You saw a sign.
Yeah, I did.
Uh...
Nan-toka...
Ha-ha...
Mizu-guchi?
Ay-te-imashu.
The, say, the...
Storm, drain, hatch.
Hook.
Doko?
Nuhahaha...
Near the sign.
Okay.
I passed it?
I did?
Oh, my God.
It feels like he's faster.
Oh, my gosh.
That's sneaky.
Oh, my God.
Was that a mine?
Oh, my gosh.
This is so messed up.
Careful, snake.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I should have...
Okay.
Save.
Run.
Does the helicopter not come back anymore?
Oh, just kidding.
Just kidding.
You can see where the mines are buried, you can?
He's trying.
Stop it, please.
This is hard enough.
Is it where that's...
Where can you see?
I can't... I can't tell at all.
You can't.
You have to use nades or shoot the brown in the original.
Wait, they didn't even give us new grenades.
They haven't even given us that.
We're all over them.
Yeah.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Let's see.
How do we wanna...
Oh, I'm stuck.
There we go.
Wait, what was that?
What is that?
What just bounced?
It's a bug?
Oh, okay.
It's spooking me.
Okay.
Sniper.
Get down, boss.
That's an enemy good ship.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I think I'm getting hit though, am I not?
I think I'm getting hit.
Oh, please leave me alone!
Okay, hold on.
Where?
There was one that I didn't use!
Where did
I...
That's messed up.
That's so messed up!
I eated it.
It despawned!
Okay, well...
I think we're just gonna...
Wait.
Hold on.
Okay, let's just run for it.
I'll...
I wish I'd do where to go.
Oh!
I think I see where the mines are.
I think I see where they are!
Oh my goodness, this is...
This is tricky.
That's an enemy good ship.
A single burst from this machine gun can cut a man in half.
Tread carefully.
Oh, it's crabs rising, not the mines.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I wish I could get rid of this stinking...
Is this where I need to go?
Please!
Leave!
Let's just hope that we get some health.
Let's just hope and pray.
Let's hope and pray.
What happened?
Ladder hard.
That's what happened.
Wait, it's the valve sound.
Woo!
I wonder if that got anybody.
Yeah!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die for real?
I don't even do...
That was just one more hit and I'm dead.
Where is it?
I think it's like right here.
No?
Yeah, baby!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
I guess I don't need to be in there.
Who are you talking to?
I don't wanna fall out and then...
Accidentally, like...
Slip or something, you know?
Cause you know I would!
Okay, baby!
Fall out?
Los Angeles?
Get him in the foot.
Oh!
How do I get that?
Do I slide?
I'm gonna make a deuce.
What's the point?
I'll just redo this part if I don't make it.
Uh...
Wait, it won't let me...
Wait...
Oh gosh!
What is it?
Shift to walk?
There we go, okay.
Uh...
The ledge?
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to get to, but I'm afraid if I jump...
Oh...
Okay...
Okay, nice!
Anybody?
Just a broken turret.
I'm creeping!
I'm creeping along!
What's that sound?
No!
I'm gonna die!
I did a hundred percent...
...percent call it.
Dang it.
I think I just lost that guy too.
I don't think he's gonna come back.
Okay, we got that one.
But where'd that other guy go?
Oh, there he is.
My flashlight?
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Now we get this guy down here.
Get his little booty.
Artichokey.
We just have to...
...not have that guy throw a grenade at us.
I think I'm just gonna have to...
I only have 18 health.
And it's because I fell.
Part of me wants to reload...
...from my last quick save.
Yeah...
I can do it!
Okay.
If you guys believe.
If you guys believe, I'll believe.
I don't believe.
Where is he?
Oh.
I got him.
Save every kill.
Stop!
That's what I'm doing!
Oh!
It's a good thing I saved after every kill, eh?
It's a good thing I saved after every kill, huh?
Wait, how do I get down?
Oh.
Where are you?
Where are you, mister?
He's already dead!
Okay, alright.
But I know what I must do.
Let's take this guy out.
Wh-where is he?
Ah, there he is.
I think.
Alright, I saw someone running.
Oh, there he is.
Nice!
Okay.
Let's attempt this again.
I think a snark is good- or rather better for...
larger amounts of people.
I'd say.
In the backpack again.
Okay, here we go.
Nice and easy.
Okay.
Oh!
Nice and easy.
We did it.
We did it!
Okay.
Good job.
Team.
Hold on.
Before we go over that way, let me see if there was anything.
Yeah, because there's like a little...
Excuse you.
Please.
There's like a...
Um...
Am I...
Going...
Am I gonna die?
Let's see.
Hold on.
Can I walk on top of this?
Now what?
Walk the rope?
Tight.
Okay.
We can do this.
And then I'm gonna kill this guy one shot.
I...
I have a little bit of blood loss.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no, no, God.
No, God, please.
Please, no.
No!
Ah!
There's so much in there.
Wait.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Yes!
Wait, where is it?
This...
This bad boy here.
Can I...
Wait, where'd it go?
What did that do?
Oh, you guided!
Okay, hold on.
It follows the laser.
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
How do I do this?
Hey!
Alt fire?
Or right click turns off the laser?
Oh!
The right click turns off the laser, yeah.
You painted my side!
Be gone with you!
Felt good.
Revenge, yeah!
The revenge!
Revenge is sweet.
Oh, okay.
We gotta keep going this way.
So then it's actually really good that we took it down, because we would've had to...
Oh, this is a ladder.
There.
Oh, okay.
We would've had to go across all of this with it still flying around?
Hell no!
I wish this was Minecraft, where if I...
You know...
If I'm crouched...
It won't...
I can't...
I think you missed a ration.
Wait, I did?
Wait...
I did?
I hear...
I...
Oops!
Oop!
Oh, it's a joke.
Very funny, Mr...
Mr. Funny Man!
Very funny!
You're so funny!
The last block should just be a really long ladder.
Don't say that!
It's terrible!
Okay, hold on.
Wait, I don't wanna use this on...
Okay.
Gosh!
Who...
Who was traversing this?
I heard...
I heard critters, so...
I'm kinda like...
On edge.
Oh!
There they are.
There's...
There's the stinking critters!
Gosh!
Alrighty, we're back...
Inside?
More
military?
Maybe they'll come to me.
What's on the other side?
Okay...
Can I get them?
What if I...
Pull this out?
Okay...
Alright, I'm just gonna go.
Wait...
Which way do I go?
Oh!
Can we up the music?
I don't think you can up just the music.
What if I throw this little guy out?
I only have one of...
One bullet left.
So...
Maybe I...
Throw a couple more?
Oh...
I think it died.
Oh my god!
Okay, hold on.
Let's try and see what the other direction does.
If I run the other direction.
Woah.
Get down.
Do not.
Kemochi!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Alright, I'm just gonna die.
Why'd the BG...
The BGM said that you're not...
It literally was just like you're not cool enough for the BGM so we're just gonna...
We're gonna... Oh my gosh, please, please, let me go.
You're not cool enough for the BGM, so we're just gonna not play it.
Throw like three?
It barely did anything before they beat him, blew him up.
Medic.
Okay.
Just one is useless?
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I don't know how to use them still yet.
If I go up...
Oh, oh, oh.
This part's tricky.
Okay, hold on.
I don't even know where I need to go, so...
Okay, throw.
Throw.
I don't think you can stealth in this park, can you?
Is that friendly fire?
Oh...
If only I had gotten that guy.
It's possible, but not for long.
Okay, maybe if I like hug a wall or something.
I'm going to save...
And see...
Because...
There was clearly some friendly fire.
Right?
So we're gonna see what the damage is.
You know...
Could be that a lot of them blew up...
Because they were silly.
Not stupid.
That's a meme.
Why is my flashlight on?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, alright, hold on.
There's still quite a few guys, it seems.
Okay, let's just use this instead.
Revolver mint a lot.
I could hear the...
The tank.
There we go.
Okay.
Why is it autoing my flashlight on?
I'm stuck.
Please, let me move.
Please, please, let me move.
Please, please, please.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Why do I have to jump crouch into the little...
Into the little hole?
Which one is the one that is...
The tank?
I'm guessing the tank is here then.
Fire in the hole.
Oops.
Oh, please, please, hold on.
Scones!
Okay, okay, hold on.
This is fine.
This is actually...
This is good.
We'll go to the other side.
We'll go to this side instead.
Okay, okay, okay.
Scones!
Okay.
Well, I wouldn't say good.
This is something.
Okay.
Use snarks.
Will it even...
I only have one left.
Will it even do anything?
Yeah, see, I didn't even do anything, you guys.
But I used him because you told me to.
Okay.
Friendly fire!
Wait, I saw him?
That was not where I shot you, but okay, buddy.
Clueless tank.
Okay.
I should be reloading.
Oh, hostile's clear?
Nice.
Um, cool.
Okay.
I don't have any C4 for the tank, but we might be able to...
Do this.
It's just saved, so why not?
It's not even smokin'.
Hit it with your cur...
Wait, there's more.
Oh, there it is!
What mission?
What's that?
It's not even smokin'.
Lookin'.
The upper part.
Aim for the tank's head.
Oh yeah!
Try the crowbar!
Okay.
I did save.
We can go crowbar it.
I can't...
Seem to get on top of it.
No!
I'm so...
You guys, I'm too strong!
I can't do that!
No!
What the heck?
That was crazy.
That was so awesome.
What's going on in here?
More health.
Nothing else.
Let's explode this.
Let's grab everything.
Oh, okay.
I can only grab a certain amount.
Um...
Let's try and see for it.
Instead.
Since we...
Anti-tank crowbar.
Yes!
Gordon split it wide open!
Holy cow!
So if I throw it...
Uh...
Good enough.
Maybe.
Not good enough.
Too far.
Uh...
Run and jump and throw.
Oh...
Okay...
How heavy is C4?
Did I get it?
Uh...
How...
How heavy is it?
Uh...
Stand near...
Okay.
Here.
Maybe like this.
Huh?
Oh my god!
Gordon!
Gordon please!
Ha!
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Maybe...
Does it take more than one?
Or...
It took damage.
Okay.
Well, I only have one left, so here's a helping.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yo, baby!
Okay.
Is there anyone left?
Because before they were like chit-chatting.
And they were like, I'm gonna go check it out.
I don't think there's anybody left.
Oh, yes, there is.
I smoke too soon.
Oh, that's silly.
Okay, alright.
The guy didn't notice the tank exploding.
He doesn't need to notice.
He doesn't need to worry his pretty little head about nothing.
I'm cooking nothing.
This looks like a trap.
She shoots and she scores, you guys.
Dang, I thought that would do more.
Oh, it's another tank!
He can't turn around, can he?
He can turn around!
Uh, okay.
Got it.
I can ignore it.
I can.
Well, what if I just...
The door is where you want to go?
This one?
Ah!
Whoa!
Most doom-sounding ever.
I... I know that.
Wait, I'm gonna reload.
Sorry.
Um, I don't wanna be at 37 health.
So, what I'm gonna do is not what I did just now.
I'm going to...
Uh...
I'm going to not get hit.
Pro- Ho- Hopefully.
Okay.
Gamer.
Just like that.
Exactly how I said I was gonna play.
Baby.
Oh, hello?
Is this...
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my God!
Bees!
Uh...
Maybe they would have friendly fired.
Maybe I messed up.
What a normal jet!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah.
Mines.
Heh heh.
Cool.
In here also?
Or...
Ordnance storage facility.
There's, uh...
Crazy noises going on in there.
Confined space.
Entry can be fatal.
Enter by permit only.
Okay.
Oh, dang it.
Uh...
Okay.
What's over here?
There...
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho!
Ah-ha-ha!
Um...
Ah...
What?
It's safe this side?
It is.
Are we sure?
Okay.
What's shooting?
Where's my permit?
Damn it.
Just normal.
Really normal.
Normal sounds are going on right now.
Oh my gosh.
It's like an actual total apocalypse going on.
Okay, nevermind.
I think I can jump this.
Nice.
Hey!
Barney!
I'm here for you!
I'm sorry, Barney.
Oh my gosh.
It's a sniper!
Is he still alive?
I
don't think I got it.
They look focused on me.
Grenade it?
Okay.
Rocket it?
Yeah, I think he's dead.
That's for killing Barney.
I don't think we've had a single Barney survive this stream.
Would you rather work here before the alien invasion or Aperture Science?
I don't know, actually.
Wait, I do want to get these.
Can I... if I... hold on.
Dang it.
What era of Aperture?
I don't know.
I think I would really enjoy listening to GLaDOS's voice though.
She's got a really nice voice.
I'm just saying.
She sounds really...
She sounds really nice.
You know, she sounds so good.
She has a pretty...
pretty sound.
You know.
What the heck is this graffiti?
Can I go in here now?
No.
Uh, yep.
Near the wall.
Uh, sorry.
We're like...
Uh...
Confined.
Inside.
Um...
There's like a lot of walls.
Just...
There's like a whole bunch of walls.
I have to go through the mines!
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's blow her up.
Here's the pistol, but I can't see them.
What?
Just supposed to shoot everywhere?
Here's the crowbar!
I think I'm about to get blown up.
I tried shooting!
Oh, I got it this time.
Oh, why did I press F3?
Okay.
Alright, you guys all saw.
Oh, I have to crawl through here.
Wait, what the hell is this?
Where are mines?
Who's shooting me?
Wait, from where?
I'm gonna see.
Oh, he's behind me, you sneaky son of a gun.
Oh!
Did you see that?
Did you see how fast he...
He was like...
At me...
Oh, you...
Oh, hold on.
We'll grenade him.
Ouch!
Oh,
I forgot to change my gun.
Oh, man.
Okay, there we go.
Is he dead?
Oh!
Nope.
Hold on.
Let's just use this then.
It's a little overkill, but you know.
Oh.
Did we kill him?
Did that kill him?
Oh my gosh.
I don't have any regular grenades.
Please stop suggesting grenades.
You can see my inventory right here.
I have no regular grenades.
The game has not given me them since I literally...
Since I literally had all my stuff taken away.
I'll try this again.
I don't think that killed him though.
I can see him picking up his gun.
This guy is immortal!
It has to be inside the hole.
So like...
But that's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to...
To get it inside the hole.
How did I die?
Was it a double kill?
Okay, I think it shot that.
And that's what happened.
Hold on.
Ah!
Okay, hold on.
Since I don't have very many left...
That's why I'm...
That's why I'm safe.
Okay!
Oh my goodness!
Gracious!
Mister!
Well, it's a good thing we shot this one down too.
Because otherwise...
That would have been bad.
Okay.
Ellen McLean voice is nice.
She's in Half-Life too.
I see.
Also, door!
Thank you so much for the gift!
And thank you!
If I blow these up...
Perfect.
That's not how that's supposed to work!
Now...
Um...
When I'm scared!
I'm scared!
Can we know?
Okay.
We got it!
We're in!
We're in, baby!
What's that sound?
Okay.
I think we're okay.
All right.
Yeah!
Uh...
Where do we go, though?
Oh, never mind.
Wait, hold on.
Figuring it out.
I've got this!
Don't tell me!
Scientists!
Are you okay in there?
What was that?
Hello!
You're heading for the Lambda Complex, aren't you?
I was heading there myself, and so I wound up here and...
Well, simply, you've lost my nerve.
Take one look through that door, and you'll see what I mean.
I'm just going to wait out the catastrophe in here.
If you intend to go on, then I beg of you.
Proceed with extreme caution.
Okay.
Nice.
There wasn't anything out there that I needed, right?
How many turrets are there?
No?
Okay, good.
How many turrets are in here?
Wait, let's get our shotty.
Good luck.
No smoking in this area.
So I can't shoot?
I'll try.
This is a test.
Okay.
That was a test.
Don't say count one!
I don't even...
That was a test!
Oh, got something.
Nice, okay.
Okay.
Maybe I...
If I jump from here...
You know?
And if I get on top of this...
Hold on.
Watch this.
Watch.
Sorry.
Okay, but that's so unfair!
It goes underneath!
How does that not work?
I should have saved after I jumped the second jump.
Okay.
Save after every step.
For real though.
Oh my...
Wait, there's something smoking over there.
Is that party?
Can I...
Go under the...
Macarena under this or no?
Oh.
My bad.
I pressed...
I did...
I did press space.
But I don't think it...
Registered.
Oh boy.
Oh gosh.
Please no.
Oh.
Where are you?
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
No jumping.
Okay.
At least we can shoot.
Why is a Barney smoking?
Cause he's smoking high.
Wait, they're both smoking.
You okay?
What's wrong with you?
Okay.
Um...
Damn right.
Which half-life letter guards that far?
That would be Barney.
Yup.
You got it right.
Oh my gosh.
It's a maze, but...
Oh.
I don't know where to go.
Okay.
Hold on.
I think I need to...
Oh gosh.
It scares me.
Hold on.
I don't want to be jump scared.
So I'm going to turn on the volume a little bit.
Hell yeah.
I did that.
I hear another guy.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Come on.
Seriously?
Oh, I can't even get up there though.
My bad.
Um...
I think I can get over from here.
I guess.
Oh my gosh.
Uh...
How am I supposed to...
Can I crouch underneath this?
Okay.
This is a crouching one.
We have to make sure he doesn't jump.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll turn it up a little because it's kind of hard to hear.
How I just did.
I didn't know what the button would do.
Don't say, me toe.
You should have broken that.
The one time I don't break a box.
The one time, literally, that I don't break a box.
Is the one time...
It screws me over.
Now how does this help me?
Is there something underneath?
No?
Hey!
Oh!
Oh, we can jump!
Okay, hold on.
I'm just looking around if there's anything else.
Um...
I want to break boxes.
But I'll refuse.
Oh my gosh, I almost...
I almost just...
How tall...
Am I?
I really hope there was nothing else in here that I needed because, uh...
Sayonara!
Breaking boxes betrays you.
What is that?
Oh!
What is this?
The bees!
It's the bees!
Please!
I wish I could...
Please give me armor.
Oh, I'll take that.
Let's definitely take that.
I'll take that.
Okay.
Save and test?
Yeah, let's try it out.
Oh my god.
So what do I do?
Watch it with that thing.
Oh, Barty!
I'm so sorry!
Barty!
I'm sorry.
Be so nice.
Just kill me.
Anyway.
Oh my god!
Sorry.
Okay.
Restart.
I can't un...
Hi.
Hi, Gordon.
Oh my god.
Take cover!
Yeah, you sure did.
Okay.
You also...
Here, come here.
Come here.
Use that.
Walk on top of it.
The pain.
Come here.
Use it.
Eat it.
I'll stay here and guard this area.
You should do that.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
You know what?
We've got...
Well, I have 48.
Let's try this out.
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe...
Maybe it's not as great as I thought it.
Use the bees.
Bees.
My party.
I'm traumatized now.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'll use the bees.
It's not as exciting as I thought it would be.
It's kind of not great.
Hold on.
Let's try again.
Oops.
My bad.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Wrong weapon.
Okay.
One more time.
I'm spamming bees!
I feel like I took so much...
Spam is infinite.
It is?
Okay.
I...
It's kind of...
Bad.
The bees don't do much damage.
Except it's me.
If it's me, I guess.
Uh...
Okay.
Well, hold on.
Wait.
Did I save already?
Okay.
No, no, no.
Hold on.
Give me a second.
Barney, don't get hit.
Damn it!
Don't get hit, Barney!
Oh.
Why did I do that?
Sorry.
I'm silly.
Okay.
Now we're good.
Now we're good to go.
Now we're all fine.
I never used the bee gun myself.
I feel like maybe if you know how to use it, it's fine.
I don't think I do.
I'm trying.
Okay.
There we go.
I tried.
I still got shot though.
Nothing in here.
Uh oh.
Someone did not make it.
I think the people that were shooting did the losing.
Barney, you okay?
There's still critters around?
What's in there?
Nothing?
Huh.
Just a box.
Huh, just a box.
There's a lot going on up here.
Oh my god.
Ow!
The bees!
Fuck.
Oh.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
I got...
Understood.
Oops.
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Airstrike on the way.
Yeah, why can't it also destroy, like, the guys that are...
...around here?
What the hell is that making that sound?
What is making that sound?
What's making that sound?
Oh.
Oh,
dude.
I'm shooting the ground.
Um...
What?
Oh, I...
Okay, okay, okay.
I see.
What the?
Yeah, there's a lot going on here.
I...
Sorry, you guys.
I'm...
I'm extremely...
...brain foggy today.
Please understand.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Sounds so stinky.
Someone said that the...
...bees regenerate?
So, bye.
Oh, there they go.
Oh, they're...
Yeah, they do regenerate.
Okay.
But they're not omen.
Oh!
Oh, something's getting done.
Hopefully these guys don't just, uh, respawn.
Oh my god.
How does he...
How does he respawn?
Oh, there's some health.
Oh, my goodness.
Thank goodness.
Oh.
Ah!
30% Okay.
Awesome.
Okay.
I'm gonna turn this off.
Save.
I just did, did I not?
Oh, he almost got stuck.
Ah!
Ouch.
Oh, a fracture?
Come on.
Eek!
Ah!
We got him.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh, my very last one even.
I don't know if I'll keep...
Wait.
Did I get all the health that was around here?
Yeah, I did.
Ah!
Okay, sorry guys.
I'm gonna redo it.
I'm gonna redo it!
Because...
I don't wanna...
...die to a fracture.
I don't wanna die to a fracture.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so...
I keep tripping on it.
Oh, we got it though.
Okay.
I guess, um...
We take these.
Who is dying over here?
Oh!
Oh, my God.
The sniper.
Seek a medical...
Oh!
Ha!
Okay.
Nice.
Uh, nice.
Okay, nice.
Watch out for the sniper, by the way.
Oh, thanks.
Yeah.
Got his ass.
Oh, I did not mean to save.
Oops.
Who's shooting?
Oh, well.
I guess, uh...
He's...
He's gone.
My man left.
But he really did leave.
Are you coming back?
Or...
Uh...
He got me good.
I'll be...
I'll give him that.
He got me good.
Ow!
I keep forgetting to reload.
Okay.
Let me reload real quick.
Before I freaking...
Okay, there we go.
All right.
My bad.
I don't even know if that was doing anything to anybody.
Oh, I have no more grenades.
Trip mine.
Where at?
The side eye.
What is this thing making the sound?
I don't like it.
Uh...
Yeah.
Shut up.
Nice.
Your friend upstairs?
Must be.
Guess we'll go meet him.
Get
over there!
Barn.
Barn, barn.
That was sick.
Thank you.
Hey.
Huh!
He won't even talk.
What did you say?
Don't go in there.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I need you to go...
Okay.
Don't...
You're scaring me!
Oh!
Nice!
Uh...
Oh!
Oh my god.
I wish they gave me...
They gave me everything but...
Help!
Just kidding!
Uh-oh.
Why?
Lock and load.
Wait, why'd they give me help?
Oh, I'm scared.
Let's get the hell out of here.
No.
Okay, I'll secure this area.
Yeah, exactly.
You stay right...
Where you are, buddy boy.
Okay, never mind.
Okay.
Alright, what do I...
There's so much going on at all times right now.
Okay.
Um...
I...
Can't go this way.
So we'll go...
This way.
Um...
Can I climb up this?
There's something in there.
I don't know...
I don't want to open that door.
Uh...
Is there anything in here?
No.
Window upstairs.
Okay.
Can I jump from this window?
Okay, okay.
Over here.
Hi.
Hooray.
Okay.
Oh, I always think it's at me.
Oh, gosh, okay.
Ah, hi.
I see, I see.
Oh, ho, ho.
Wa-boo!
Woo-hoo!
I came too hard.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
I came too hard!
Oh, can I destroy their satellite system?
Oh, boy.
Okay.
Maybe I shouldn't have saved.
I messed up.
Hold on.
I think I messed up.
The bees, the bees.
Scones.
Are the bees doing anything?
You know what?
I also have grenades now.
What am I doing?
Oh, my God.
Ouch.
Everywhere.
Oh, my God.
It's just a grenade war.
Why did I... What the... Oh, because I... Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Did I take that hit?
I must have.
Wait, hold on.
No, I didn't.
I'm losing.
Wait.
Or...
The... It changed.
It was 54 before... Oh, wait.
I'm stupid.
Why did I do that?
What if I... Okay, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Let me...
I don't think there's as many guys down here that I think there are.
Worms gameplay.
The visible planes.
The better bee-siness bureau.
You know there's a lot of buzz around our bees.
So we're sorry.
They were below your expectations.
Can we make it up with some freebies?
Yeah.
It is pretty disappointing.
I'm not gonna lie.
Like, I really did think that there would be...
A little more oomph to these bees.
I mean, they're like...
Supposed to...
You advertise as the...
You advertise as the bees' knees.
And that just doesn't seem to be the case.
It's just really not holding up to...
The expectations.
To the...
You know...
What we all had...
In mind...
Did I...
I think we're okay.
Oh!
On a...
Scale?
Like...
Like a grading scale?
I wouldn't even give them a bee.
You know?
It's just that...
This is scary.
Oh!
Wait, this is scary.
Where am I supposed to go?
Maybe back up?
Uh...
Can I go back up?
Yes.
I can't believe it.
Parkour time.
But to where?
Oh!
I need to go to that floor.
Okay, I see it.
Oh.
Ah-ha.
Okay.
Saved where I initially wanted to.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh...
Can I even make this?
Wow!
I did it!
Uh-oh.
Uh...
I've trained in Minecraft for this.
Let's just see what's gonna happen.
Pain ahead?
No way.
Shoot the rotors.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh!
Pain for them, maybe.
And me.
My
bad.
My bad.
I need to prepare for them.
No fish!
Ah, I'm wasting them.
Aim at the floor.
Oh, that would have been better, huh?
No.
Ugh.
VTuber, please.
Hey!
Um, I don't know.
You know what?
Let's do it again.
Let's do it.
Let me try it.
Maybe with grenades instead.
Hoey!
Oh.
Okay, not with grenades.
Okay, hold on.
They're too bouncy.
Um, shoddy.
Crossbow, I have limited.
I only have...how much do I have?
I only have 20!
This works!
Okay.
We saved.
We should be okay for now.
They're not as tough as they look.
That concerns me.
A little bit.
That...that concerns me a little bit.
Wait, I wish I could blow...can I blow that up early?
Let's chip.
Let's try.
I can use it.
Oh.
That's exciting.
That doesn't concern me.
That excites me.
You can't blow it up.
Sorry.
I have Metal Gear Brain right now.
Oh.
Okay.
Stop.
It's unmanned.
Yeah, but I thought maybe someone would come and man it.
So much for...that.
Oh.
Let's redo.
Wait.
Uh...yeah, I'm on it.
Okay.
Oh my God.
At least...I...took less...damage than I did before.
I think.
Okay.
Ugh.
Chunky.
Yeah, you're so chunky.
Okay.
Is there anything in these?
Please, say yes.
Oh, they...I can't destroy them.
Beep, beep.
Oh my God.
Oh.
Uh...
How do I...
How do I...man you?
Wait.
Please.
Uh...
Barney can open that door.
Oh, true.
Okay.
Oh, we have to bring them all the way here?
What's in here?
What's in here, actually?
That's what I was hearing was that guy...
Oh, there's a shortcut.
Barney!
Barney, Barney, Barney.
Barney, come here.
I won't let anything happen to you.
Okay, why not?
Actually, hold on.
Let me...
Really?
I have full ammo of everything?
I was gonna say...
There's no...
There's no way.
I'll bet that stings a bit.
Come on.
Come here.
There we go.
Okay, come on.
Uh...
This way.
This way, Barney.
Barney, Barney.
This way.
Barney?
Are you lost?
Oh, come on, come on.
Come on, buddy.
You go on without me.
No, no, no, no.
Come here.
Roger that.
Let's run like hell.
Okay, come here, come here.
Come on.
Is he stuck?
Are you stuck on the door?
This place is a lot bigger than I thought.
I can't push him, you guys.
No, please.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Oh, okay, thank goodness.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, here, here.
Open this.
Please don't die here.
Please.
Barney.
Barney, I'm...
I'm right behind...
I'm right here to get anything.
Don't run!
Where did I go?
Oh, what are you doing?
Nice.
He's a free man!
Okay.
Barney, watch out.
There could be...
There could be anything afoot.
I don't know if we should go any further.
What you were saying?
Anyway, you stay...
Oh, what's this?
Oh, I can't grab it.
Yeah, let's go.
No, no, no, no.
You stay here.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You come here.
Come here.
Okay.
We might live longer if we work together.
Come here, come here.
Open this.
Oh, just kidding.
I'll stay here and guard this area.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, what am I supposed to...
...do here then?
Can in the door?
I tried!
Did I not do a good enough job?
Oh.
Oracle boom.
Other door, left side.
That one.
I tried.
Ah!
Ah.
Shoot Barney.
You wish.
You okay?
Yeah, he's fine.
Maybe a little traumatized.
Okay.
Bye Barney!
We...you guys, we kept one Barney alive.
Oh.
Why didn't I reload sooner?
We kept one Barney!
Oh.
What are those?
Oh no, they're like respawning.
Oh gosh.
Use the gun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
Uh oh, uh oh.
Is
that it?
Oh.
Think
we're good.
Minto Rambo.
Yeah, baby.
Maybe.
Um...
I wanna call it soon.
But I don't know where to call it.
You know?
I wanna...
I'm having fun still.
But I am getting a little...
Tired.
So...
I don't know...
Where to call.
Now?
Now's a good time, is it?
End of chapter soon?
Okay okay okay.
Uh...
If I can find...
How to...
Is...
Skip.
The middle?
The blob?
Really?
I got to go with that?
I got to go with this...
Oh, it's a trampoline.
This guy's talking from the dead.
I'm gonna get my grenades up.
Okay.
Is that me?
Oh, no.
I don't know what they're fighting.
Who will win?
I can't tell.
Who won?
Was that a robot?
Or... Who is that?
Mean toe will win.
Was that the bees?
The snark?
The big alien.
Okay, hold on.
Redo.
Sorry.
I don't want to use my... I don't want to use my crossbow for that.
Every time I go in a hole, I know I should... I know I should not use crossbow.
Or like, you know, I should equip something like this.
Just in case it's a headcrab too.
I'm getting a taste of my own medicine.
What the hell are those?
Oh.
Got it.
Oh, wait.
Let's go get... Let's heal again.
Oh, crowbar.
Yeah, crowbar.
I forget that I'm crouched.
So it would be easy.
Come on.
You can do it.
I believe.
Nice.
There we go.
Come on.
Crouch.
Jump.
No.
Use your fists.
Control space.
Yeah.
That's what I'm doing.
Yep.
Yeah.
That's what... That's what that is.
I think it's too high, guys.
It's too high.
It's not me.
I know how to crouch jump.
It's too high.
This bait?
I guess so.
Wait.
I'm stuck.
AHHH!
Space microbar!
Tick die!
Oh god, I'm really about to die.
I made it.
I lived, somehow.
That was quite cinematic, it really was.
Here, I'm gonna redo it.
And I'm gonna use my gun instead.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, I'm gonna reload.
The thrill of reloading in battle.
All right, let's go.
Oh, uh... That's right, I got him.
We took way less damage, I don't know.
Hookie dokie!
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Awesome.
Awesome!
Yippee!
Oh!
Uh...
Yes.
Wait, what is this doing?
Actually.
Just notice these.
What did I do?
What?
Go for a drive.
What kind of car is this?
Car nerds.
All car otaku rise up.
What car is that?
What the?
How'd that happen?
Scones!
Let's scones!
It is a really big car, yeah.
There we go.
Um...
Can I...
Uh...
Dang it.
Let me see...
Maybe this one?
No?
I thought I would lift it.
The switch?
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, the...
Ah!
Oh.
Uh...
Wait.
That was...
Less than ideal, but...
Got the job done.
Let's scones!
Okay.
And we...
Boop!
That worked somehow.
Alright.
Let's get to that gun.
No bees today.
No bees tomorrow.
No...
No bees any day!
I hear no more footsteps.
Yeah!
Damn!
I'm guessing...
Is this another...
Another...
Nipple trampoline?
Or...
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Alright.
Onwards.
Your military forces are pathetic when they're getting their asses kicked by a theoretical physicist.
They are so...
Did you see them over there?
Come on!
I literally threaded the needle.
There's someone still down here.
There we go.
S-save.
Well, okay.
Saved.
Okay, good.
No!
The bees!
Um...
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Uh...
More bees.
Maybe...
peach fractures.
I don't think that...
Worked!
Woooo!
Oh...
Bees, bees, bees!
Bee, bee, bees.
, be, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo.
Bug-b-bees, bu, bu, bu, bu, buh, buh, buh, bu...
Please...
What do I...
Want to...
Throw?
Use MY bees against HIS bees?
Counter the bees!
Jeez.
Can I bait him?
Where'd he go?
I don't think it hones, even if you... unless you, like, see the guy, it seems.
Kinda sucks.
Uh, let's see.
Maybe I can bait him if I...
Oh, did I get him?
Oh, I got him!
That worked!
Nice.
We were able to use it.
Okay.
Or, we'll switch to this.
Before we go over that way.
Oh, wait.
I just saved it, didn't I?
It's fine.
Anything in here?
For me to take?
Oh.
We got some stuffs.
And... this stuffs.
Good stuffs.
Good stuff.
Awesome.
I wish... I wish I could have whatever's in there.
So much stuff!
Awful.
Aaaaah.
Gustav's room!
Ah.
If I weren't already dead, I'd be telling you to kill me again.
Ha ha ha ha.
Or kill me.
If I weren't already dead, I'd tell you to kill me.
Okay, we got to parkour this one, guys.
They left us the tiniest platform ever.
Who am I hearing?
I'm hearing a bee, ma'am.
You could call him a bee-lister.
Before you end, there's a little custom spray for you and your general tag.
A what?
Sure, I'll take it.
A tea spray.
Well, how do I... equip that?
Oh my gosh.
There's another one.
I like how this is... these are the guys we're fighting now.
Yo, the tea...
Like that?
Wait, how do I...
Could I...
How do I...
How...
Wait.
So, if I...
In my general tag...
If I...
How would I upload it, though?
Oh, in multiplayer!
I don't see...
I...
What?
What is...
What is this?
I just went to my general tag and hit latest.
And...
I don't like what I saw.
It works for single player, too.
I don't see it.
Maybe...
Is it like the hashtag mint phantom?
I don't see it.
Oh, I see it!
Thank you!
Okay.
Select it in settings under multiplayer.
And press T.
Thank you!
But it has to be in multiplayer?
Now wondering.
Don't...
Don't worry about it.
That's the general tag, no?
What, hashtag mint phantom?
But I have one!
It's the...
The hashtag...
I have it labeled as general.
I mean, they're both kind of general.
But the...
Mintoshin, Leishashin...
It used to be my...
Fan art tag.
And now...
But because, you know...
Nihongo-muzukeshi...
Uh...
I changed it.
But now that's...
Technically the general tag.
But...
Anyway.
Anyway!
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
Um...
Where was I?
I'm just gonna save.
I don't remember.
The last time I saved.
Okay.
I love blowing people up.
Did he run?
I think I only got one guy.
I got one guy.
Did he go around the corner?
Oh, he exploded.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, you got me.
No, not me!
No, don't get me!
Get the guy over there!
Wait.
He'll think it's the bee man.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, friendly fire!
Friendly fire!
We got him.
Oh, it was his bees?
I can't tell whose bees are mine.
I'm using his bees.
I'm using your bees against you.
I'm using...
Ouch!
Wait.
I'm using your...
I'm using human technology against you.
Did it?
Work?
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
Okay, never mind.
I'm not using human technology against you.
It's flawed!
It's flawed.
We got him.
It's flawed!
Okay.
Now we can jump down, I guess.
Or...
Hold on.
Let me go heal again.
Ancient human tech.
Quick.
Actually.
The technology is fine.
It's the technique.
Um...
Uh...
If it wasn't...
If it were actually not flawed, then...
Anyone would have been able to use it.
And it would have been...
Perfect.
So...
Um...
Actually...
It was flawed.
Oh.
Because if it weren't flawed, then anybody...
Would be able to use it.
No problem.
Just saying.
Sure, sure.
That's...
That's the honest truth.
Where is the exit?
You ca...
What the?
Oh, that's a dead guy.
Hey.
Quit running.
Stop.
Stop it.
Stop skipping.
Nice.
He's got the zoomies.
He's just an excited little man.
Huh.
Actually...
I can't tell where those sounds are coming from.
Let's use our shotgun.
Okay.
Where am I hearing this from?
Where am I hearing all the noise from?
Oh.
Oh!
I thought it was a person.
Oops.
Okay.
Anyway.
Um.
Let's redo that.
Oh no, please.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Whee!
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
Alright.
Nothing around here?
Okay.
Take it.
Half-Life classic, truly.
Oh, wait.
Let's put on our shoddy and go in and... Okay, I'm in.
How much longer is that?
Okay.
Can I get this guy?
I still take so much damage.
Are you kidding me?
How did they know I was in here?
Oh, I should have crouched.
Oh, here, I'll redo it.
Oh, I thought being in the water was good enough.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Hold on.
Maybe I can get this guy, too, though.
Okay, everybody.
Scones!
Nice.
Or, maybe I shouldn't... It's too late.
It's fine.
I was gonna say, maybe I should use the crossbow instead, but...
How does this thing stay intact?
Oh.
Only Gordon had a helmet.
The time for a nade?
You're still right?
Oh, I think I got something, though.
You think he's dead?
Yeah, I think he's dead.
Send in the bugs.
I think I got a turret that was here.
Medic!
It wasn't me.
Oh, it's a headcrab!
Holy...
Medic!
I don't wanna use that.
I'll just...
Can the... Can this attack...
Oh, it does.
Nice.
Aw, he... He won!
Oh, he was capable... He was actually...
Actually competent.
He was competent for once.
Oh!
And then he exploded!
Why?
Okay, I guess I'll go down, no.
Wait, what's that?
What does that do?
Uh...
Oh!
I did it.
Uh...
Okay.
Alright.
I don't think I wanna go...
Oh!
I'm...
Oh, dang it!
I wasted it!
Here, I'll just...
There we go.
Okay, just in case.
That's it?
I go inside?
There's nothing down here?
Okay.
Go in.
Yeah, I'm at a hundred.
I was thinking...
Um...
Something else.
Okay.
Quick!
Why's it gotta be like this?
Okay.
There...
Come on.
Go in.
There we go.
Oh.
Okay.
Doesn't that unused heal stay there?
I think so.
Yeah.
Let's...
Let's get our crossbow, just in case.
Alright.
If anybody throws a...
C4 in...
Um...
I'm...
Almost prepared.
Quiet down!
Sillies.
B-1 oooohh.
Stand back.
Gah...
Barney!
Were you making all that ruckus!
Gah!
Oh my god!
I almost killed Barney again!
Gah!
Who was making all that sound?
That guy!
Gah!
I thought it was upstairs.
Okay, Barney, come on.
Yeah, yeah, come here.
Come on, Barney.
Crossbow is so OP.
It's awesome.
I love it.
Okay, um... Yeah, actually... Oh, my bad.
I have so many, so we'll just keep it.
Come on.
Yeah, come on.
Follow me, buddy.
All right.
Take your time.
Take your sweet old time.
That's fine, too.
Come on.
I need help.
I know.
All right.
What's going on in here?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I'm back here.
Sure.
Then, um... Ouch.
Okay.
Uh, do I need him to unlock that, too?
I think so.
Go back for Barney.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on, Barney.
Yes?
Okay.
Yeah, we might stand a better chance if you're team up.
Yeah, exactly.
Come on, Barney.
I'm afraid of what's around this corner.
Okay.
You're safe?
All right, buddy.
I need help.
Open her up.
I'm ready.
Oh.
It's this door.
Thanks, Barney.
Thank you.
See you later.
Don't die on me.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I thought the cha...
Did I get one guide about the chapter being almost done?
Oh, gosh.
Hold on.
Wait, can he see me?
Did that even hit?
I don't know, actually.
The gun doesn't work?
Why doesn't it work?
It ends once I kill it.
Oh, great.
Love that.
I can just run?
Okay.
We'll do that.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna have...
I'm gonna hold on to our little buddy for good luck.
Do I need the trigger room?
Whoop!
I'm running!
This guy...
Is just holding on.
Oh.
Wait.
It didn't bounce me.
It doesn't bounce me.
Uh-oh.
I am jumping.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my god.
I'm running and running and running and running and running and running... I did it!
First try!
Okay, that guy is... Oh shoot, where is he?
Wait, I don't even know where I am.
Okay, hold on.
There he is!
Okay, cool.
He doesn't know I'm here though.
I'm in the middle.
Okay.
And so is he.
He's like in the perfect position right now.
I think if I move it down a little...
Like that...
The round thing is this... There's a couple round things!
I... Okay, let me... I wish... Okay, hold on.
I'm here, right?
I... I jumped into... I jumped on from this...
To... Into here.
Oh wait, or I'm here.
Wait.
So I think this should be it.
Oh!
He ran right into it!
Oh, he's angry now?
Oh, I messed up.
Okay.
Alright.
Well...
Oh, I see it!
It's like right there.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then...
There.
It's like that.
Okay.
Are you kidding me?
World's weakest!
Nope.
I didn't have the homing on.
Oh.
I don't think...
I think if I move, he'll...
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Uh...
Alright.
More like that, maybe.
But he like, ends up moving...
Can you even one-shot him?
I don't know.
You have unlimited shots?
Okay, okay.
I'm just gonna keep going then.
Oh!
Yippee!
Okay.
I got him.
Yeah!
Alright, okay.
Nice.
Uh, that was good.
Good job, team.
Yeah!
Okay!
Yay!
Uh...
Now where?
Two?
Oh...
Uh...
Um...
Back from where he came, I guess.
I guess.
Oh, I gotta destroy the walls.
I gotta blow on more things?
Oh, like these?
Okay.
What...
What is back where he was at anyway?
Oh, no.
I messed up.
Thank you, yeah.
Okay.
Like, that wall right...
Okay, okay.
Oh, and the towers.
Okay.
Um...
Does that thing then need to be blown up?
Stop wiggling!
Gosh!
Does this need to be blown up?
Oh, dang it, you...
Blow!
Okay, I guess not.
Okay.
That should be good.
Just
kidding.
Oh...
Ow!
Uh...
Like that...
Oh my gosh!
I have to blow up that thing?
There we go!
Oh my gosh!
And you.
Okay.
Alright.
He's shaking so much.
Oh!
Lucky, lucky.
Okay, nice.
And then...
That thing I gotta blow up?
Bye!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Yes, to make a bridge.
Oh...
Interesting.
Is it this?
Close.
Break everything.
Alright.
That should be all of it, no?
Nice.
The wall?
And a...
And a wall.
Which...
A wall?
The wall?
The wall.
Break the other wall.
Which wall?
The...
Oh, that wall!
Oh...
Okay, okay.
This wall...
She shoots...
And she scores.
I don't know why I'm so bad...
At determining this.
I just...
Disorder my Mint Wipocop.
Thank you, Ron!
Thank you!
There we go!
Okay, okay, okay.
I was gonna say, why...
Okay, I'm not gonna lie.
I was like...
Oh, maybe there's something I need to jump over here and then walk around.
I didn't realize that.
I couldn't...
Get to it from there.
Okay.
Maybe they've made an autosave?
Let's see.
It blows in...
I can't aim for the water, you guys.
It...
Shoots me...
It shoots me in.
It...
It shoots me...
Every time.
Crouch in the corner.
I gotta get to the corner first, buddy.
Maybe...
Classic Half-Life experience.
They tell you...
I get...
I get yelled at if I save scum.
I get yelled at if I don't save scum.
I can't make everybody happy!
People...
People in the comments are just like, She saves too much!
People in the comments, She doesn't save enough!
There's no winning!
Anyway, thank you, guys.
I'll compromise by aiming to make everyone unhappy.
Yeah!
My...
That's...
That's how...
That's my optimal gameplay style.
To just piss people off as much as possible.
Ducky, thank you for the...
Thank you, guys!
For the stream!
Oh my goodness!
Wait, how long have I been going for?
Oh my gosh!
Almost five hours now!
Wow!
I didn't expect to play for so long.
Dorko, thank you so much for the peek!
I meant it as a compliment.
Thank you!
Wishing you a brain fog-free relaxing 10 out of 10 today.
You did it, I always believed.
No matter how bleak it seems, somehow I always make it out, huh?
How many more chapters do we have?
Let me see.
Uh...
Hmm...
Huh?
Five chapters.
I looked it up earlier to see where we were at, but like...
Uh...
One, two, three, four, five, six!
Seven?
Seven chapters left?
You're like 75% through the game.
So we might...
Be able to...
Beat it next week?
This chapter was the longest.
You're about two thirds in.
Okay.
Took me about two and a half hours from this point.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Rafa, welcome to membership.
Thank you, Apache!
Thank you for the...
Thank you!
Hmm...
One more long stream.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, maybe.
You got past the longest, hardest chapter of the game and got out of the death loop.
Proud of you, Vito.
Thank you!
The last few chapters are pretty short.
Okay!
Three to four hours?
That's totally easy!
Yeah!
Maybe two more streams or a long one.
Oh yeah!
I think if...
We could do like this length, I think we could do it.
Austinaria!
Thank you so much for the fun gift!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
That was the hardest part?
What?
Seriously?
Just got your gamersubs merch.
Thank you, Onyx!
Thank you!
Everybody's saying different times.
I think...
As long as it's not like...
To me, a long stream is like seven, eight hours.
Nine hours.
If we're like five hours, I think we can easy peasy do it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Twenty hours.
Fifteen hundred hours!
Seventy five...
Four...
Hundred...
Bajillion...
Million...
Never ending hours.
So many hours.
Fukuro, thank you!
Wait...
Hundred...
X plus one hour.
Yeah.
Sixty nine, four twenty hours.
Four twenty, sixty nine hours.
Now you guys are being ridiculous.
I'm getting...
I'm getting one guide in the chat.
How many hours it's gonna take me...
To...
To beat the game.
Fibonacci hours.
Solve this...
Solve this riddle.
Riddle me this.
How many hours does it take...
To...
Have a monkey...
Change a lightbulb.
And that is your answer.
Means it's getting shorter for stream.
Thirty minutes tops.
Yeah.
What is the...
I'm so curious.
I wanna see a speed...
Speed run of this game now.
Actually.
I want to see a speed run.
Can you unpause and just press W into that room?
Sure.
Let's see what we're in for next week.
Oh.
It literally...
It literally breached my toes.
My toes didn't die.
Falling rocks.
Okay.
That's the next thing that we remember.
Where are you?
For this chapter?
Run baby run.
In the next episode.
Yeah.
That was your preview.
That was your next episode preview.
Next episode preview baby.
Thirteen of nineteen.
Wait.
But the...
I'm on the...
The fandom.
The wiki.
It says Endgame is 20.
So...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Just kidding.
Chapter 18 and then Endgame is chapter 19.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Sorry.
I was looking at the...
At the table of contents and not the chapter number.
Okay, cool.
World record for this whole game is like 20 minutes.
Like...
What?
You...
Endgame is cutscene credits.
Oh, but I thought this game didn't have cutscenes.
Oh, okay, cool.
20 minutes and 41 seconds.
What's a...
Oh, TAS.
Is it a TAS run?
Or is it...
Is it like...
Real...
People.
Half-Life 1 in 20 minutes.
TAS is shorter?
What?
Oh my god.
Glitch allowed probably.
Yeah, it has to be.
No?
Probably some skipping tech.
It has to be.
There's no way you could get here in 20 minutes.
There's no way.
I wanna know without...
Without...
Without glitches.
25 minutes is the art...
No way!
Speedrunners find a way.
The game is really broken so it has a lot of skips.
It reminds me of like Pokemon.
Original Pokemon is just being held by duct tape, you know?
But it's so crazy.
I feel like I played a lot of like...
Original Pokemon...
As a kid, right?
Like...
And I tried all sorts of things.
And...
Never once did my game glitch.
Ever.
I tried to get like a missing no and stuff.
Never!
Ever did my game ever glitch.
What did I do right?
I never had anything.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you, Papilla.
Yeah.
Task Tool Assisted Speedrun.
Basically...
Is having...
I like...
Oh, gosh.
Well, I don't...
Sometimes...
I watch like Mario task runs because they're kind of fascinating.
Where it's like...
How...
Crazy...
They can get...
How much more precision they...
They find.
It's so crazy.
I got missing no in Pokemon Red.
I came too hard.
Truly!
Oh...
Brain Age task?
I haven't watched that one.
I'll have to watch it.
Half-Life in .5A presses.
Hahaha.
Turururu puru.
Hmm.
But yeah.
Thank you guys!
Night-night Minto.
Goodnight!
Thank you for hanging out with me.
Thanks for...
Helping me through some of these.
I really appreciate it when you guys are just like...
Minto!
Do this!
I'm like, okay!
Thank you!
So thank you for helping me out.
When it's like, you gotta destroy the wall and destroy this and destroy that.
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
And next time, maybe we'll beat it.
Maybe.
Surestie, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It does help a lot.
Appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Full glitches run is 6 minutes 50 seconds.
Okay, if it's only 20 minutes, Ron, I'm gonna watch it right after this while I eat something.
Because I'm hungry.
Even though it's midnight for me.
But I eat something and then I'm gonna go to bed and then I'm gonna have crazy dreams.
Crazy.
Don't... Oh, wait, yeah, I shouldn't watch it.
Spoilers, you're right.
Okay.
Aw, man.
Okay, never mind.
I'll watch it next week.
Okay, I'll watch it next week.
I almost spoiled myself.
You were like...
I was like, yeah, no problem.
Easy.
Next week.
We'll beat it.
Maybe.
I'll try.
I'll do my best.
I'll game next week.
I'll game next week, you guys.
I will, I will, I will.
Anyway, otamito.
Thank you guys so much.
Thanks for hanging out.
And have a good rest of your day.
Rest of your night.
Now it's our fault.
No, it's not your fault.
You saved me.
Birthday time, Mr. B.
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
In memory of all the Barneys we lost along the way.
No.
See you next week for the next Otamito Healthcare Plan to Solve It.
Please.
I don't need healthcare.
I'm a ghost.
Otamito.
Salute.
O7 in the chat for all the fallen Barneys today.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop